Meine Herren, zack!
Oh, ich wollte das noch hören.
Nein, nein.
Der hat sich so schön verspielt die ganze Zeit.
Ich muss sagen, dieses Geklimper und dieses komische Gesinge am Ende von diesen komischen T-Notes, das geht mir ganz schön auf den Sack.
Ich finde das okay. Wollen wir erstmal eine Schweigemilute einlegen?
Den iPod Classic?
Eigentlich hieß er nicht. Es gab mal eine Zeit, ich weiß, da könnt ihr euch alle nicht mehr dran erinnern, da hieß der, bin ich drauf überhaupt?
Nee, ich schneide dich ja immer raus.
Ach so, mit die Schweigemilute besser funktioniert.
Genau.
Da hieß der iPod Classic nicht iPod Classic, sondern iPod.
Ja, wir haben noch ein bisschen Echo drauf gehabt. Aber ich glaube, wir könnten auch die Akustik noch ein bisschen verbessern, oder? Du möchtest gerne das Fenster offen lassen, ne?
Frischluft ist super, ja.
Also, da das ja jetzt schon der Anfang der Sendung ist, sollten wir vielleicht mal begrüßen. Hallo, hier willkommen bei Mobile Max Ausgabe Nummer... Nein, noch nicht die 50. Aber die 49. haben wir jetzt schon zusammen. So sieht's aus. Ich begrüße, ich begrüße in der Runde Max, mir gegenüber, direkt frontal, trinkend.
Ist auch nicht so viel, Max. Ich muss diesen Pizza-Geschmack aus dem Mund kriegen.
Pizza-Geschmack willst du aus deinem Mund kriegen.
Ja, ich hab ne Special Pizza genommen, das ist immer ein Fehler, da sind immer nur eklige Soßen drauf. Na ja, irgendwie sowas.
Immerhin haben die diese Keynote genutzt, um vorher mal was zu essen, ne? So, heute Teilnehmer Nummer 2.
Von Flettergeld, vielen Dank dafür.
Genau. Liebe Flappizza. Flappizza.
We are so flattered.
Ja, sagt der Hucke.
Hallo. Von der Pizza hab ich gleich so einen Frosch im Hals. Also ich würd ein Wodka nehmen, ne?
Du würdest ein Wodka nehmen. Ich hab, glaube ich... Noch ein.
Ich muss noch mal gucken. So ein Rachenputzer.
Rachenputzer. Naja, jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal unser Hirn putzen. Will mich auch noch einer vorstellen?
Wer bist du?
Ich, ich, ich...
Dennis war schon letztes Mal weg, jetzt ist Tim auch mal weg.
Ich bin hier nur der Todtechniker und Streaming-Genieur.
Alle neidisch auf unsere Flatterkohle. Uns gegenüber, Tim, ne Theodor, wie war der Spruch?
Tim Fritlav.
Tim Fritlav. Aber du hattest auch noch so einen...
Diskordischen Namen.
Theodor Prinz der Tapfere.
Hüter der Flamme.
Flamme des Herzens.
Haus der Apostel der Eris.
Ja, genau, genau, den studiere ich zum nächsten Mal ein.
Aber ich bin nicht in meiner diskordischen Eigenschaft hier, sondern ich bin ja hier in meiner offiziellen Rolle als Fanboy des Apple Universums, stets dem heiligen Steve an den Lippen hängend. Das haben wir jetzt hier auch die letzte 1,5 Stunden gemacht.
Du warst richtig nervös.
Ganz treu, ich war nervös.
Ein bisschen schon.
Ich war konzentriert, das ist was vollkommen anderes.
Also komm, als du gesagt hast, iTunes 10 und du, da bist du fast umgefallen vor lauter...
Nee, als ich gesehen hab...
Das könnte Coco sein, das könnte Coco sein. Also das hast du nicht gesagt, aber so ähnlich hast du reagiert.
Nein, in dem Moment, als da die Zahl 10 stand, wusste ich, dass es das nicht ist.
Weil es kein X ist?
Weil es kein X ist. Ich dachte ja immer, sie nutzen die Gelegenheit von 9 auf X und dann irgendwie All New und so weiter. Aber die haben einfach so einen Featuredruck, so eine Pine am Start, dass sie einfach überhaupt nicht mehr in der Lage sind, dieses Programm jemals in die 64-Bit-Ära zu bringen. Ich meine, auf Adobe rumzuhacken, mit irgendwelchen Public Letters wie sehr sie doch irgendwie zurückhängen und irgendwie ja, und ihr kriegt ja noch nicht mal 64-Bit hin. Und ihr beklopptes, publikes iTunes, wo sie es jetzt irgendwie nach zehn Jahren geschafft haben, mal das Icon zu wechseln. Und ansonsten tut sie nicht viel an dem Programm, außer dass es langsamer wird.
Wer bist du und was hast du mit hin gemacht?
Leute, mal ehrlich, dieses Programm geht nicht. Ich meine, da kannst du noch so ein Fanboy sein.
Aber die Close Boxen sind jetzt untereinander.
Da kannst du noch so ein Fanboy sein, wenn irgendwie... Wie soll man das vertreten? Ich meine, für iTunes kann man sich doch eigentlich nur schämen. Weil es gibt durchaus Aspekte, die finde ich nach wie vor gut an diesem Programm. Dass es überhaupt mal so integriert ist. Nein, natürlich, es gibt ja auch sonst eigentlich nichts ordentliches.
Ja, das ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem.
Ja, das ist das Hauptproblem. Aber was mich ja allermeisten stört, gerade jetzt als Podcaster, ist, dass dieses Programm verbessert seit fünf Jahren. Also es gab ein einziges Update, wo sich mal was getan hat mit dem Podcasting. Ein einziges Update, wo was besser wurde, nachdem sie es ursprünglich mal eingeführt haben. Und das war's. Und sonst tut sich da einfach nichts. Fünf Jahre, keine Innovation.
Mit Podcasting kann man kein Geld verdienen.
Mit Podcasting kann man kein Geld verdienen. Die Leute kaufen sich iPods.
Und Steve hat gesagt, die Leute wollen auf ihren Dingern keine, die wollen eine Hollywood-Produktion. Hier nicht so Amateur-Scheiß.
Ist dein Mikrofon irgendwie leise?
Ja, mein Mikrofon ist leise, sag ich doch.
Warum denn eigentlich?
Jetzt sag ich mal was. Bin ich jetzt ein bisschen lauter?
Ich verstehe gerade nicht, warum.
Wir schalten nun in den Technik-Block.
Sprich mal weiter, Max.
Auf jeden Fall mag Steve keine Podcasts mehr, nachdem er sie mal mochte. Und darum ist das jetzt scheißegal geworden.
Ach, der hat doch hier eben auf seinem Apple TV auch wieder Podcasts erwähnt. Ja, das ist da irgendwie ein Feature.
Wer ist eigentlich dieser Podcasten?
So müssen wir das nicht anfangen. Bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei iTunes. Ich will nicht so sehr darauf rumhängen. Ich verstehe ja, dass Sie sagen, okay, Podcasting, das hilft uns nur dabei, irgendwelche Geräte zu verkaufen und so. Wir nehmen den Content und wir machen auch noch dieses iTunes-Directory und wir haben sogar zwei Leute pro Land, die das irgendwie kuratieren und da Podcast-Logos zusammenschnippeln, damit die dann irgendwie in ihren Store passen und dann wird man nochmal gefeaturet. Das ist ja auch alles vollkommen in Ordnung und das zeigt ja auch, dass es Ihnen nicht vollkommen egal ist. Das Problem ist nur, dass spätestens mit dem iPhone ist halt der ummauerte Garten, den dieses iPhone betrifft, muss halt alles durch iTunes durchgehen. Und ich hatte ja neulich diesen Fall, als ich hier BitTorrent eingeschaltet habe. Dass die Leute natürlich verständlicherweise auch die per BitTorrent bezogenen Podcasts gerne auf ihrem iPhone hätten, als richtige Podcasts gelistet. Und es war einfach nicht möglich, das hinzubekommen. Es gibt da diesen Flag, diesen Media-Type, den man in iTunes setzen kann. Du kannst sagen, das ist eine TV-Show, das ist ein Audiobook, das ist ein Podcast. Gibt's auch noch mal extra so einen Typ. Und es ist auch immer ganz wichtig, wie der gesetzt ist. Je nachdem taucht er halt in einer anderen Kategorie auf. Und wenn du sagst, das ist ein Podcast, dann taucht er eben auch in dieser Podcast-Kategorie auf. Aber jetzt kommt der Brüller. Das speichert er offensichtlich nicht im File, sondern nur in seiner Library. Das heißt, wenn du dieses File nimmst und irgendwie Big Moves und Perbittorren überträgst oder was auch immer, oder auch einfach nur von einem Computer, das hab ich jetzt letzten Tage irgendwie viel gemacht, nimmst einfach rüber und dieses Setting bleibt nicht erhalten. Also zum Beispiel auch, was weiß ich, Audiobücher. Ich hab jetzt hier so Kinder-CDs mal irgendwie gerippt und so weiter. Da sind auch so viele Geschichten dabei. Hab ich natürlich auch als Audiobook getaggt und dachte ich so, okay, alles klar, dann nehm ich so die Dateien und übertrag die dann auf den anderen Rechner. Also jetzt nicht so zwei iTunes nebeneinander sehen sich und Homesharing und so weiter, weil das ließ ich so nicht machen, wollte ich auch nicht machen. Hätte auch lange zu lange gedauert. Und naja, dann vergiss einfach dieses Setting wieder. Was noch dazu führt, dass es dann auch noch irgendwie, dann vergiss er auch noch seine Cover Art, weil dann hängt das auch noch irgendwie davon ab, was das für ein Typ ist und ob das eine Compilation ist oder nicht. Also es ist einfach schlimm. Und was ich möchte, ist, dass sich dieses System entweder, entweder sollen sie da was dran tun oder sie sollen sich öffnen. Dass man also in irgendeiner Form die Podcasts auch anders da reinbringen kann. Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass sie da eine eigene Infrastruktur hätten oder so. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie einem Download Space oder sonst irgendwas bieten würden. Sie haben nur dieses Verzeichnis und sonst machen sie gar nichts.
So.
So viel dazu. Und iTunes X hat es nicht gegeben, jetzt gibt es zehn. Und was ist das tolle neue Feature?
Neue Zeichen!
Man kann jetzt hier die Album Cover Art bei fünf dargestellten Titeln, dann spart man sich eine Spalte.
Na hurra!
Nee, Ping! Gut.
Kommen wir also zum elementaren Inhalt dieser Kinos. Was haben wir denn mitgenommen? Wollen wir irgendwie von vorne nach hinten durchmaschieren? Okay, also vorne hat er erstmal rumgebragged, wie cool sie doch sind.
Also erstmal ist dir Huckel ja gleich was aufgefallen.
Ach ja, Huckel dir ist was aufgefallen? Was ist dir denn aufgefallen?
Er hat doch mal schnell......dass er keinen Rollkragenpulli anhatte.
Ach so, der Pulli nicht in der Hose steckt da ja. Was er sonst immer macht und wodurch er immer extrem dünn aussieht.
Wie der geschlackert oder was?
Ja, er hat so irgendwie den Pulli draußen gehabt. Und nicht so einen richtigen Turtleneck, sondern eigentlich eher so ein Longsleeve-Shirt. So ein bisschen hipper auch jetzt vielleicht.
Hat er denn noch New Balance-Schuhe angehabt oder?
Da müssen wir nochmal kurz Instant Replay. Nee, aber auf jeden Fall hat er sich scheinbar so ein bisschen hipper gekleidet, ja. Das ist mir gleich aufgefallen. Ich als...
Das war nämlich gar nicht Steve.
Als Apple Style-Berater.
Gut. Aber abgesehen von der kleiner Kultur...
Womit haben sie angefangen?
Womit hat er angefangen? Der iOS 4.1 kommt nächste Woche ran. Tolles Feature, HDR-Fotos. Das HD-Video-Upload über Wi-Fi?
Das hat mich nämlich total geärgert. Ich hab nämlich ein Video hochgeladen, dachte so, was ich mit dem iPhone 4 gemacht hab, mittlerweile hab ich ja auch eins, das auf dem Display wirklich großartig aussah und dann hab ich das zu YouTube hochgeladen, das sah echt scheiße aus. Also direkt übers Gerät.
Ja, weil er eben nicht die HD-Variate auflädt.
Ja, furchtbar, furchtbar.
Was ich übrigens auch bei dieser HD-Kamera gerne hätte, wäre das, wo sie HDR machen, das geht ja eigentlich am besten mit RAW-Images. Also man kriegt da nicht die RAW-Images vom iPhone, aber das wäre eigentlich cool.
Kriegt man nicht?
Oder?
Ach so, RAW hat er nicht wahrscheinlich. Nee, das stimmt.
Also das wäre eigentlich mal auch noch so ein cooles Feature, jetzt ohne HDR machen. Naja, anyway, aber auf jeden Fall gibt es HDR-Fotos, das ist ja schon mal auch ganz cool.
Dieses HDR ist einmal vernünftige Belichtung, einmal überbelichten, einmal unterbelichten und dann daraus eine okaye Variante zusammenrendern. Ich hab irgendwann nochmal gehört von irgendwas, das sollte so funktionieren, und zwar, dass man zwei Fotos macht. Eins macht man mit einer langen Belichtung, das dann ruhig verwackeln kann, um die Farben richtig hinzukriegen und eins mit einer kurzen Belichtung, um die Bildschärfe zu haben. Also, dass man im Dunkeln, wenn man im Dunkeln, da hat man ja das Problem entweder das Verwaschen, man hat ordentliche Farben oder man hat ein scharfes Bild, aber das ist dann viel zu dunkel. Und das dann gibt es, das ist das nicht. Also nicht HDR.
Nee, HDR bezieht sich meines Wissens ausschließlich auf die Belichtungsdauer. Ich bin ja kein Experte, aber HDR...
Du kannst halt einfach...
Damit kannst du halt echt Unreal Photography machen. Also wir haben das zum Beispiel bei Blinkenlights extrem viel benutzt, um gute Fotos von den Gebäuden zu bekommen, die dann später in diesem Simulator gut aussehen oder in diesen Editoren.
Und bessere Kameras kann man schon ewig, oder wie?
Du kannst das ja von Hand machen. Also du kannst mit einer guten Kamera, die haben sozusagen die Möglichkeit, ein ganzes Set von Fotos zu machen. Und dann nimmst du diese, die also unterschiedliche Belichtungszeiten haben, und dann nimmst du die halt, also auf dem Stativ, dass du immer das gleiche Bild hast, und dann nimmst du halt diese Fotos und jagst das durch irgendein HDR-Tool, der es verschiedene gibt.
Und was die da machen, ist das jetzt sozusagen automatisch machen, dass du die nicht einzeln runterladen musst und konvertieren musst oder zusammen puzzeln musst, sondern die machen dir gleich einen HDR-Tool.
Genau, sie machen auch mehr oder weniger dann so drei Bilder in einem. Aber das ist natürlich die Verwackelung. Das wird nochmal ein echtes Thema sein. Also so aus der Hand... Im Prinzip, ja, müssen wir mal sehen, ob das dann zu verwaschenden Fotos führt oder ob sie tatsächlich sogar noch so eine Korrektur machen, dass sie da, weiß ich, die Bilder miteinander vergleichen, wie sehr du die verwackelt hast, zwischen Foto 1 und 2, muss man sehen. Aber es ist jetzt auch kein, wie sagt man, keine Rocket Science, aber auf jeden Fall ein cooles Feature. Und gerade, was er da auch demonstriert hat, das war auch immer bei uns immer so das Ding, du kriegst einfach geilen Himmel, weil du einfach den Himmel nicht mehr überstrahlt, bzw. er eben sieht, wo es überstrahlt und wo nicht. Und du kriegst halt einfach die richtigen Tiefen unter, was auch war so diese typische Situation. Taghell, die Sonne strahlt, und du hast so ganz harte Schlagschatten irgendwann von irgendwas. Und dadurch entstehen halt diese krassen Kontraste. Und je nachdem, ob die Kamera sich eben auf den zu hellen oder zu dunklen Punkt eins schießt, ist es halt entweder zu hell oder zu dunkel. Und mit der Methode wird das eben auch ausgeglichen.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, was sie da raustun. Weil eigentlich gibt es ja selten 16 Bit JPEGs. Aber eigentlich spiele ich mir auch immer 8 JPEGs. Also pro Farbkanal 255 Farben und so weiter.
Kann durchaus sein, dass sie das intern auf Raw machen.
Das nehme ich auch an, weil anders kriegst du da keine guten Ergebnisse hin. Und was du dann halt machst, weil die Kamera immer nur so in einem bestimmten Bereich der Helligkeit auf einmal mappen kann. Du hast halt, sagen wir mal, eine 10-Stufe um Helligkeit zu mappen. Wenn jetzt ganz krass hell und ganz krass dunkel dabei ist, dann verlierst du halt sozusagen Detail. Und was du da machst, ist halt sozusagen in drei unterschiedlichen Belichtungs-Settings aufnehmen und die dann übereinander legen, dass du deine dynamische Helligkeit, also den Bereich vergrößerst.
Also, dass man den Bereich aufbläht sozusagen.
Ja, und eigentlich kommen halt so bei diesen HDR-Fotos auch immer 16-Bit-Files raus, aber wahrscheinlich werden sie danach wieder runterrechnen, wenn da kein RAW runterkommt. Na, da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, so.
Könnte spannend werden.
Naja, also für...
Was haben wir noch? iOS 4.1 bringt gut, HD-Upload haben wir schon gesagt. Dann irgendwie hier so TV-Show-Rentels, da können wir noch gleich zu Game Center. Muss man mal schauen. Ich meine, das haben ja im... Da sind wohl ein paar nette Features drin und sie haben natürlich dann auch wieder The Power of User Accounts, weil ja im Prinzip jeder, der ein iPhone hat, hat schon ein Apple Store Account. Das heißt, du hast das einfach out of the box und musst dich nicht bei irgendeinem OpenFind oder wie die alle heißen anmelden.
Ja, für die wird es jetzt echt eng.
Naja, gut. Die haben natürlich den großen Vorteil. Die unterstützen auch alle IOS-Versionen. Apple geht halt erstmal ab 4.1.
Und sie können plattformübergreifend.
Sie fangen...
Plattformübergreifend, genau.
Genau, das ist halt alles nur. Ich bin mir sicher, dass eine Menge das einbauen werden, wenn es nicht zu schwer ist. Das wird einfach auftauchen. Und ich denke, dass einige dann wahrscheinlich auch die eine oder die andere Option anbieten. Ob man das oder das benutzt, muss man sehen. Es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, das einzubauen.
Das wäre noch alle einbauen.
Ich meine, wenn sie damit damit werden, dass sie größte Spieleplattformen überhaupt sind, auf Mobil, dann.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn du sowas hast wie DoodleJump, was jetzt schon seit drei Jahren im Store da auf Platz eins ist, und dem jetzt auch keine Updates mehr einfallen. Und dann kommt Apple und sagt, hier gibt es Game Center. Klar, macht ihr sofort ein Game Center-Update für DoodleJump. Was?
DoodleJump fällt nichts mehr ein? Da gab es neulich erst neue Themes.
Das ist immer der Beweis, dass ihr noch was einfällt. Wenn sie Themes machen, dann fällt ihnen immer noch was ein.
Das Spielkonzept ist halt schon sehr eindimensional, möchte ich mal sagen. Das machen alle. Gut. Ich werde von Dennis herausgefordert werden. Ich sehe es kommen.
Was ich ja noch viel interessanter finde, ist dann der Ausblick auf iOS 4.2. Was hat er gesagt? Anfang November? November? Ja, da kommen dann die Features, die man haben will, iPad-Support.
Endlich. Endlich aufs iPad.
Und vor allem Wireless-Printing hat er ja auch demonstriert.
Hätte ich auch gerne auf dem Phone?
Das werden wir dann auch auf dem Phone haben. Also hat nicht gesagt, das ist nur auf dem iPad. Hat das nicht sogar auf dem iPhone demonstriert?
Er hat es auf dem iPad demonstriert, aber iOS 4.2 wird dann im November auch für iPhone und iPod kommen, mit anderen Worten. Dann ist es bestimmt so weit.
Ja, das iPhone wird dann drucken können. Was ich mich frage ist, welche Drucker...
Das ist eine spannende Frage.
Und in dem Zusammenhang kann ich auch gleich noch ein anderes Thema einbringen, was ich hier ansprechen wollte.
Aber kann ich nur kurz dazwischen? Welche Drucker?
Ja, welche Drucker?
Also, ich hab ja hier mit, wenn du Drucker in den Mac anschließt und die da eingerichtet hast und da Printer-Sharing anmachst, ab dem Zeitpunkt muss ich ja sagen, funktioniert Drucken über Wireless und so weiter echt problemfrei mit Macs. Hab ich jetzt erst kurz wieder im Büro getestet.
Wenn du einen Mac dazwischen hast, der sozusagen nach außen dich von diesem Treiberscheiß entstellt.
Genau, du machst auf dem Mac alles klar mit dem Drucker und dann sagst du Printer-Sharing.
Genau, nur dass du dann den Drucker halt zweimal siehst. Du siehst ihn dann halt auf dem Mac und dann siehst du ihn halt den Drucker nochmal als solchen, was jetzt vielleicht noch zu erschlagen ist, aber im Zweifelsfall hast du dann immer noch irgendeinen User, der wieder nicht weiß, wo und wie.
Aber da steht ja immer AD-IMAC oder AD-MAC-MINI hinter.
Ja, ok, klar, super.
Also das wird auf jeden Fall gehen.
Ich hab so einen HP-Multifunktions-Klimbim. An sich sind die ja ganz interessant. Ich find die ein bisschen zu billig. Das macht mich immer stutzig.
Die verdienen halt immer noch...
Bei mir verdienen sie nicht so viel an Tonern, weil ich kauf nicht den Toner auf einen HP. Ich kauf hier Toner bei Tonerbilligladen.
Tonerbillig, also B-I-X.
Interessanter Punkt. In dieser Printcenter-Software hat Apple ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge kluge Sachen eingebaut. Ich bin insgesamt mit dieser ganzen Printing-Experience auf dem Mac nicht zufrieden. Aber es ist mal wieder schön, was es da alles für Button gibt, die dann mit den jeweiligen Druckern aber nicht unterstützt sind. Also bei Tintenpissern gibt es definitiv die Möglichkeit, dir dann auch gleich die Fill-Levels anzeigen zu lassen. Aber wir unterstützen halt diese ganzen Drucker dann irgendwie nicht übers... Welches Interface auch immer.
Wenn du den... bei manchen geht es. Wenn du ein Driver installierst, also schön von der Webseite runtergeladen und so, dann geht das doch meistens.
Ja.
Und ich hab noch nie einen Drucker gehabt, der nicht Netzwerk konnte. Also seit 20 Jahren. Ja, weil was anderes kam mir noch nie in den Sinn. Drucker irgendwie so direkt an den Computer über eine Serie der Schnittstelle anschließen, das ist einfach... Das ist einfach bäh.
Wobei der Style-Fighter damals war schon cool. Der schmale, der war super.
Jetzt reiß nicht die alten Wunden wieder auf.
Naja, wie auch immer. Ich bin mal mit dem QMS PS410 gestartet. Super. Und worauf wollte ich hinaus? Multifunktions-Support, Drucken und so weiter, das geht ja mittlerweile. Gut, das ist ein gelöstes Problem. Aber sich so richtig in das Betriebssystem hinein zu integrieren, oder anders gesagt, dass der Drucker einfach die richtige Sprache spricht mit dem Rechner, das ist so eine Sache. Das merke ich immer wieder bei meinem HP Drucker, wenn ich da nämlich mal scannen will, oder faxen, da hat er dann so alle möglichen Tasten und dann muss ich da so eine Software installieren, so ein HP-Müll, weißt du, mit so merkwürdigen Installern, die wohl so komische 10% CPU-zeitfressende Demons im Hintergrund sind und du weißt auch nicht, wie du das deinstalliert bekommst. Und dann sind das so Tools wie zum Beispiel diese Scan-Software, wo du dann zwar in manchen Fällen dann auch was gescannt bekommst, aber geh mal nicht davon aus, dass du Leerzeichen in deinem Dateinamen verwenden darfst, wenn du das dann abspeicherst und so einen Scheiß. Also wirklich, im Jahre 2010 wagen die so einen Dreck auszuliefern und bekommen wirklich das kalte Kotzen und ich werd das nicht nochmal kaufen. Da war ich neulich zufällig, stand noch so eine billige Plastikschachtel, dachte ich zumindest, ist es wahrscheinlich auch so ein Brother, auch mit Netzwerk, auch mit Scannen, auch mit Fax. Und ich hab dann irgendwie einen neuen iMac daneben eingerichtet und war total erschlagen, dass dieses Gerät einfach so funktionierte, und zwar mit Scannen. Nein, in dem Druckcenter-Dialog gibt es einen Scan-Button. Ich dachte, ich sterbe. Wann ist das denn dazu gekommen? Das war wahrscheinlich seit 10, 6. Doch, doch, das ist ganz hervorragend. Ich habe einen Icon für dieses Gerät.
Ach so.
Und ich kann darüber scannen. Also Fax hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Aber ich kann darüber drücken und scannen. Und das funktioniert. Ich hab da einfach gescannt. Und richtig mit Tray-Auswahl, ob das über ein Dokument hinein zu kommt oder von der Glasplatte. Ich dachte, ich sterbe. Irre. Und das hab ich schon häufiger gehört, dass diese Browser sich extrem gut integrieren, wo HP schwächelt. Ich hab jetzt bloß noch keinen Browser gefunden, der mir jetzt so zusagt, da werd ich dann auch noch mal.
Ein Spechelsinn im Zusammenhang mit HP, würde ich da in den Samenkoch einfach sagen. Versagt, oder? Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass ich mal irgendwann, ich musste was scannen oder ausdrucken, ich weiß es nicht mehr, und ich musste erstmal bei HP 170 MB Treiberot anladen. Und dann musste der Rechner neu gestartet werden und danach ging im Dock, ich glaube, drei oder vier Icons an, rumzuhoppeln. Und dann hast du da, um das zu drucken. Das bildet ihr euch ein.
Und keine Updates.
Dann gibt es keine Updates für die Scheiße. Dann hört die Software irgendwann auf zu funktionieren. Und es gibt keine Updates.
Und diese ganzen Malprogramme, die sie dazu installieren und weißt ja toll, was die da an dich haben.
Und sind die der Lage, selber mal zu checken, ob es ein Update gibt oder überhaupt mal zu wissen, welche Software man überhaupt nur installieren soll. Schäm dich, HP.
Die haben es auch echt schleifen lassen. Also wirklich grausam.
Wobei, noch schlimmer finde ich, da bin ich ganz kurz, finde ich Lexmark, die für wirklich so ein Büro haben wir so einen sau teuren Farblaserdrucker, der ist irgendwie ein halbes Jahr alt oder ein Jahr oder ich weiß nicht, also kein altes Teil. Für den gibt es nicht mal mehr Windows 7 Treiber. Und die alten Treiber, die gehen zwar so halbwegs, aber das stürzt da regelmäßig mit ab. Und das machen die einfach. Das ist vorbei. Das war bestimmt ein 3000 Euro Gerät oder sowas.
Das ist echt bizarr. Das ist wirklich grausam. Aber insofern finde ich jetzt diese Nachricht mit dem Wireless-Printing ganz cool. Weil das bedeutet, funktioniert mit jedem Drucker, der sich ordentlich verhält. Weil Treiber installieren auf dem iPhone, wird es nicht geben. Entweder hat dein Drucker einen Works-with-iPhone da drauf oder nicht.
Aber ist das deine Konkurrenz? Oder machen sie das zusammen? Google hat doch auch so ein neues Drucken, so ein Cloud-Printing.
Er hat Google gesagt.
Cloud-Printing? Ich hab mich leider nicht so richtig mit beschäftigt. Die wollten nämlich auch, dass dieses Drucken endlich mal vereinfacht wird. Nein, nein. Ohne bezahlen. Das hab ich übrigens überlegt, ob dafür vielleicht dieses neue E-Brief gut sein könnte, dass wenn man keinen Drucker hat, dass man sich einfach selber so eine E-Brief-E-Mail zuschickt, die man dann zwei Tage später ausgedruckt im Briefkasten hat, für 55 Cent, was ich in echt okayen Service fände. Ja, aber das wollte ich gar nicht sagen, sondern Google hat auch ein bisschen was in der Richtung schon angekündigt, dass sie das jetzt mal langsam so ein bisschen entwickeln wollten, zusammen mit ein paar anderen. Und ich weiß leider nicht mehr, welcher Drucker-Hersteller, das war der in Zusammenarbeit mit Yahoo, die auch so einen übers Netz vernetzten, also übers Internet vernetzten Drucker hatten, der dir dann Werbung ausdruckt.
Das klingt wie ein ganz tolles Feature, was wir unbedingt diskutieren müssen hier. Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus?
Dass es auch noch andere Internetdruck, andere Initiativen gibt, das Drucken zu verbessern.
Internetdrucken ist so das eine und Drucken auf dem eigenen Drucker ist so das andere. Man will ja mit dem iPhone irgendwo hingehen und im WLAN direkt Discovery das Teil sehen und drucken.
Ja, genau darum geht's Google ja auch. Die wollen ja für ihr Chromo, es wollen ja auch nicht 3000 Treiber unterstützen. Ich will das scannen.
Das wär auch cool. Stell dir mal vor, du hättest so einen kleinen Bluetooth-Visitenkartenscanner.
Hab ich netzlich iPhone.
In der Tasche. Achso, der kann man abfotografieren. Scannen ist Quatsch. Ich vergesse euch jedes Mal wieder, dass man irgendwie auch Kameras benutzen kann. Nee, vergiss es. Nee, wie auch immer. Ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Und das war wichtig, dass das kam. Bzw. es ist wichtig, dass es kommt, denn es ist noch nicht da. Sondern erst im November.
Also ich persönlich finde es überhaupt nicht wichtig, aber es gibt unglaublich viele Leute, die sagen, und wie druckt man damit? Und jetzt kann man, indem man Drucken drückt.
Ja, ich glaube darauf läuft es auch hinaus. Na gut, zur Apple TV und dem Airplay kommen wir gleich noch mal. Vielleicht nochmal kurz die iPod-Geschichte abreißen. Ja, also er meinte ja, es gibt jeden iPod neu. Das ist gelogen. Den iPod Classic gibt es nicht mehr.
Der ist jetzt invisible.
Also vielleicht gibt es den ja noch.
Das beste User-Interface ehe wahr.
Gibt es den vielleicht? Guck mal, iPod Classic ist hier noch aufgeführt.
Du meinst, die werden einfach noch weiterverkauft, oder was? Ist schon aktualisiert?
Just 249. Immer noch 160 GB.
Aber irgendwie ist da diese Aussage falsch gewesen. Wir haben alle iPods neu designt.
Ich glaube, diese iPod Classic, der lebt in Steves Welt überhaupt gar nicht mehr so richtig. Was ich viel interessanter fand, war ja die Aussage...
Mein Steam wurde verheimlicht.
Können wir das besser mal zumachen? Ich finde es ein bisschen laut da draußen. Interessant fand ich die Aussage, dass der iPod Touch mittlerweile der meistverkaufte iPod ist. Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt etwas überrascht.
Ich hatte so den Eindruck, dass es eigentlich schon eine Weile so ist.
Den Eindruck und den hattest du weswegen?
Wegen irgendwie bei diesen Quartalszahlen oder so, da war immer schon der iPod Touch ganz schön weit vorne dabei.
Die haben den iPod Touch Quartalszahlen nie genannt. Sie reden immer nur von iPod und da war der iPod Touch dabei. Sie haben bloß zwischendurch, da habe ich jetzt aber nicht die Arithmetic gemacht, immer mal wieder gesagt, wie viele iOS-Devices es jetzt gibt und dann hätte man sich das so ein bisschen rausrechnen können. Aber das hat ja nichts darüber gesagt, wie viele von den anderen sozusagen, die ja auch noch verkauft wurden. Aber gut, so scheint es nun zu sein. Zumindest wird es behauptet. Genau, von Chefe. Und naja, dieser neue Apple Shuffle ist ein Bug-Fix, würde ich sagen. Ja. Also das habe ich ja überhaupt nicht verstanden mit dieser Sprachsteuerung. Weil eins kann ich dir sagen zum Thema Sprachsteuerung, das will keiner. Also ich habe das erste Mal vor, sagen wir jetzt, 2010, ich habe vor 18, 17 Jahren das erste Mal mit Sprachsteuerung von Software irgendwie rum experimentiert und das willst du einfach nicht.
Hast du schon mal die Google abprobiert?
Nee, die ist gar nicht schlecht.
Da kannst du sagen, Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2 und du kriegst Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2, und zwar mit Röhmisch 2.
Ernsthaft?
Funktioniert extrem krass gut.
Du redest von dieser Google...
Pass auf, wir probieren das hier einfach raus. Ach so, ich muss hier ein Netz an... Doch, WLAN kann ich ja so machen.
Also ich nutze auf meinem iPhone immer die Spracherkennung, um Telefon nochmal zu wählen. Das funktioniert so mittel.
Das funktioniert bei mir überhaupt nicht.
Sei mal kurz leise. Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2. Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2.
Ist ja unglaublich. 2 hat er dir auch rausgesucht.
Kannst auch.
Und dann relativ zu Berlin oder was?
Das ist in Berlin, ja. Unglaublich. Mit Location Service, keine Ahnung, wie sie das tun, aber die haben extra... Also ich meine, sie können ja die Spracheingabe korrelieren mit ihren Suchergebnissen und so weiter. Also sie können ja da irgendwie richtig abgehen mit, was die Leute da wohl haben könnten, wollen. Und also wenn einer das mit dieser Spracherkennung nochmal lösen kann, da sind die Google-Jungs scheinbar weit vorne.
Das ist aber auch was anderes. Also das ist Suche, wovon ich sprach, ist das Steuern deines Computers.
Open my browser. Wie wir da früher da gesessen haben.
Aber es funktioniert bei mir immer erstaunlich schlecht. Es gibt also Suche und Auskunft, da spielt das eine Rolle. Zum Beispiel, wo wir gerade dabei sind, bei diesen ganzen online Auskunftssystemen über Telefonauskunftssystemen, wird das ja auch schon lange verwendet. Aber ich rede jetzt nicht von wenn Sie ein technisches Problem haben, sagen Sie technisches Problem.
Bitte sagen Sie jetzt eins.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt besonders doof vorkommen, sagen Sie, ich komm mir doof vor.
Bitte sagen Sie Ihre PIN-Nummer laut und deutlich und achten Sie darauf, dass oben liegende Leute Sie nicht verstehen.
Buchhaltung, Rechnung, Aktennotiz.
Aktivieren. Du weißt, was der beste Tipp ist, durch solche Menüsteuerungen durchzukommen?
Nichts sagen.
Dann wird man irgendwann vermittelt.
Einfach schweigen. Von Anfang an.
Es gab irgendwann mal eine Software, die konnten an dem Maß, mit dem du die Tasten drückst, haben die wohl gemessen, wie aggressiv du schon bist. Und dich dann einem entsprechenden trainierten Mitarbeiter zugewiesen.
Das kann gut sein. Ich glaube, das ist auch sehr viel mehr darum geht, sozusagen die Frustration zu messen. Es gab ein interessantes Auskommenssystem.
Es geht auch darum, sie hoch zu treiben, gerade wenn sie als Telekom oder sowas.
Naja, ich weiß noch, ich war ja damals in diesem aufkommenden Telefon- Mehrwertsdienstmarkt tätig. Und da gab es dann auch eine interessante Anwendung von Philips. Das geht so ein bisschen in diese Google-Richtung. Die haben so ein Wahnauskunftssystem geprototypt. Ich meine, dass dieses System bis heute so nicht zum Einsatz kam. Ich weiß nicht warum. Vielleicht waren das zu teuer oder keine Ahnung. Das hat aber sehr adaptiv gearbeitet, weil du dann immer, du konntest einfach mit dem, naja, was heißt das, mit Menschen reden will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber du musst es nicht an den linearen Narrationen folgen. Normalerweise von wo möchten sie losfahren? Piep! So, ja, und dann musst du dich da so durchhangeln und wenn du später halt irgendwas falsch gemacht hast, darfst du da von vorne anfangen. Und bei denen war das ganz anders so. Die haben erstmal gefragt, was willst du?
Wer bist du denn?
Dann kannst du sagen, ich will nach Hamburg. Wohin? Von wo möchten sie nach Hamburg fahren? Das heißt, er hat sozusagen seine Variablen dynamisch gefüllt, um sozusagen alles irgendwann zu wissen und hat dann immer so die Sachen hinterfragt, die ihm noch fehlen. Sehr kluger Ansatz. Naja, aber beim iPod Shuffle, um mal wieder zum Thema zurückzukommen, scheint das alles irgendwie nicht so richtig gefruchtet zu haben. Die Leute wollten Knüppe haben. Gerade bei diesem kleinen Wurstel-Teil. Ich meine, jetzt hab ich auch nicht verstanden, warum sie da jetzt unbedingt das alles weglassen mussten. Ansonsten finde ich den Shuffle überhaupt nicht so interessant.
Also ich finde ihn natürlich.
Ja, aber ich höre ja nicht Shuffle.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber ich hab schon mal überlegt, ob ich mir einfach einen hole, um einen zu haben, aber das denke ich jetzt natürlich je über Nano.
Genau, jetzt gibt es den Shuffle auch in Bründ, aber dieser Shuffle kostet jetzt nur noch 49 $.
Aber ich kenne echt viele Leute mit dem Shuffle.
Jaja, Shuffle.
Also auch in der Bahn oder so, siehst du lauter Leute mit dem, also nicht mit dem neuen, also immer noch mit dem.
Den habe ich auch nie gesehen.
Den habe ich nie gesehen mit dem neuen.
Und den konnte man ja auch nicht mehr sehen. Weil den muss man wieder in die Tasche stecken.
Aber den mit den Knöpfen, also diesen Clip mit den Knöpfen, den habe ich echt oft gesehen.
Der Clip mit den Knöpfen.
Ja und jetzt gibt es den Clip mit dem, ohne Knöpfe, aber mit Touch.
Und? Was denkt ihr?
Wird bestimmt.
Praktisch. Du meintest noch, wozu braucht man denn da überhaupt Multi-Touch, wenn man da eh nur ein Finger drauf passt?
Ja, also das ist wirklich so. Das hat doch Briefmarkengröße.
Ja, aber hast gesehen, wie sich Steve abgemüht hat da mit seinen Wurstfingern. Es ist genau. Er hat den falschen Rollkrankenpullover aus dem Regal rausgenommen. Und nicht in die Hose getackt.
Ja, und wenn sie jetzt noch weiter integrieren...
Das war sowieso immer ein bisschen störend, weil das machen eigentlich nur so Nerds.
Ja, oder irgendwie so Spießer.
Und wenn Steve Jobs einzustand, dann weder Nerd noch Spießer.
Spießer-Nerds. Also diese Rotate-Geste, das ist genau das, was ich für das iPhone haben will. Und das können Sie bitte nächste Woche einbauen. Na was, Christe, nicht. Das ist ja wohl iOS 4.1, was auf dem Scheißteil läuft.
Und ich meinste, das ist ernsthaft iOS 4.1?
4.1 lite.
Auf eine Nano?
Na was denn sonst? Meinst du, die portieren ja noch ein 2.0 oder was?
Na ich weiß nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass, also meinste, die haben da die Hardware drinne, um so ein iOS laufen zu lassen?
Das ist iOS. Das hat er erstens gesagt.
Hat er das gesagt?
Das ist ein Mac OS.
Zwei eins hast du das, warum sollten sie mit einem anderen OS jetzt das ganze User-Interface nochmal nachbauen? Da war doch alles drin.
Weil sie es schon den ganzen Jahr gemacht haben. Weil auf deiner Time-Capsule kein iOS läuft.
Auf meiner Time-Capsule, die hat auch keinen Multi-Touch.
Kommt doch an, wo du es anfisst. Wenn du in den Stecker greifst.
Ich würd das noch nicht mal wundern, wenn... Nee, ich glaub der Shuffle hat es nicht, aber...
Aber ein Darwin läuft da bestimmt drunter. Also auf jeden Fall. Und da drüber ist halt irgendwie so ein runtergestripptes... Wie heißt denn das Framework eigentlich?
Also das wird nicht den vollständigen Umfang eines iPhones haben. Und da ist sicherlich keine Telefon-Applikation drauf. Aber das ist iOS.
Also wir haben jetzt Unix in Portemonnaie.
Die haben da 128 MB RAM drauf wahrscheinlich. Oder vielleicht auch nur 64. Das passt schon.
Also ich weiß es nicht. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, das um Akku zu sparen und so was. Und das um die Produktionskosten gering zu halten.
Akku zu sparen. Was gibt es denn Besseres als iOS, um Akku zu sparen?
Na irgendein total kleines, was gerade mal so MP3 abspielen kann.
Ein total kleines OS.
Genau, Multitasking wäre da nochmal interessant gewesen.
Es ist iOS, Punkt. Er hat es gesagt.
Ob dann auch ein Jailbreak kommt?
Er hat es gesagt. Aber die Frage ist, ob es überhaupt erst mal Apps gibt. Wenn es ein Jailbreak gibt, dann ist ein neues SDK fällig. Weil das ja wahrscheinlich wieder eine ganz andere Geschichte ist. Da gibt es keinen Home-Button. Da musst du irgendwie auf Bildschirme drücken. Das finde ich schon ein bisschen so.
War das diese Verkleinern-Geste oder war das der Hold-Button?
Nein, einfach nur festhalten war der Home-Button.
Ah, okay.
Genau. Einfach so drauf drücken.
Wo ich mir gedacht hätte, wenn das noch einen Klick hätte, also wenn es so wie bei einem Touchpad, so ein Glas-Touchpad, das hat ja Touch und hat ja Klick. Und wenn sie das noch beim iPhone machen würden, dann wäre das auch so eine schöne Geschichte.
Wozu ein Klick, wenn die Leute touchen?
Ja komm, hier der alte iPod mit dem Klick-Wii, also die iPods mit dem Klick-Wii, hast du das selber gesagt?
Egal, ich möchte über diese Geste sprechen. Das ist für mich sehr wichtig, psychologisch, ja. Weil ich empfinde es nach wie vor als eine Frechheit, dass einfach dieses Rotate-Log-Problem nicht gelöst ist. Ich hätte es gerne folgende Änderung, machst da Doppelklick, kriegst da irgendwie dein komisches Multitasking-Menü, swipes nach links und dann steht da Scroll-Log. Und dann machst du das irgendwie an und dann gibt es kein Autorotate mehr. Und zwar überhaupt nichts. Und dann habe ich aber diese Geste, sodass ich jederzeit zwischen Landscape und hin und her schalte. Das will ich haben. Weil ich will einfach mal will ich es so und mal will ich es so. Und dieses OS weiß nicht, wann ich was will. Das könnten sie natürlich auch lösen, dass sie da irgendwie so ein Brain Implant noch irgendwie dazu liefern. So iBrain, was man da so reinstecken kann, was dann über Bluetooth das ganze Hirn gesteuert macht, meinetwegen auch noch das oder so ein Babelfisch, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall muss dieses Problem gelöst werden. Es kann aber nicht sein, dass so ein teures Luxusteil sich von einem wegdreht.
Also so weit geht meine Fanboy-Liebe zu Apple noch nicht, dass ich mir von denen was reinstecke.
Na so sauber sieht aber dein iPhone nicht aus.
Obwohl ich jeden Tag abblecke.
Was machst du denn mit deinen Kopfhörern?
Der Nano, der ist schön klein.
Die Kopfhörer hat das nicht immer nur in die Ohren.
Aber die Leute werden, die Developer werden wahrscheinlich jetzt bereits schon die ersten Bugs feilen und sagen, iPod Nano hat einen Bug. Kein STK, ich will dafür programmieren.
Ja, das wird bestimmt kommen.
Ich glaube ich nicht, du wirst es nie machen.
Die hatten aber auch auf dem iPad Spiele drauf. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das auf den letzten Generationen auch noch hatten, aber früher hatten sie Spiele auf dem iPad.
Was könnte man denn für geile Ups mit so einem iPod Nano machen?
Viele Uhren.
Spiele? Viele Uhren.
Mit echten Songs, keine Ahnung. Also auf diesem kleinen Screen ist es schon echt schwer. Also Doodle Jump könntest du noch machen, vielleicht. Aber jetzt so...
Pitchen, Audio irgendwie.
So ein paar Gesten-Sachen.
Also wenn du den Ding in der Hand hier, wie bei der V, ja.
Ob der Beschleunigungssensor oder nicht.
Hat der Beschleunigungssensor?
Obwohl, das wäre natürlich... Da könnte natürlich sein, dass die einfach nicht nutzen, dass sie einen mit eingebaut haben, auch wenn die nicht nutzen.
Das sind so viele Unbekannte noch. Gibt's ja nicht...
Warte mal, den Beschleunigungssensor... Wie machen sie denn das mit dem Rotate?
Wir haben ja keinen Auto-Rotate.
Wir haben keinen Auto-Rotate drin.
Schlimm. Aber der alte... Also der alte Nano hatte auch einen Beschleunigungssensor schon drinnen. Warum sollten sie den weglassen? So teuer kann er nicht sein.
Ja, aber was haben sie denn damit gemacht?
Shuffle. Dass du geschüttelt hast, ne? Das ist Shuffle. Total albern, aber... Aber das Apple so einen billigen...
Das ist natürlich bei so einem Teil, was du irgendwie dran klippst, irgendwie... Das Shuffle ist ja nicht...
Ja, natürlich, aber... Dass die jetzt einfach sowas, genauso wie sie im iPod irgendwann mal Bluetooth offensichtlich eingebaut hatten...
Sensor, Accelerometer.
Ach, steht sogar auf der Webseite.
Und ein Büro auch?
Wofür nutzen sie diesen Sensor am Augenblick? Für nüscht, oder? Also da haben sie noch was vor mit dem Bank.
Also ich stell mir das Ding ja mehr so als Visitenkarte vor.
Hallo, my name is...
Du kennst doch dieses Problem, du gehst auf eine Konferenz und hast einfach keinen eigenen Batch. Dann läufst du mit unserem blöden Mercedes-Benz, Nokia-Bändchen durch die Gegend und kommst dir blöd vor. Aber wenn du so einen Teil hast, dann kannst du da so eine...
Dann kommt man sich nicht blöd vor....
Ja, aber dann hast du da irgendwie deine eigene Visitenkarten ab, die du startest und wo dann so dein Firmenlogo drauf ist.
Chris Einbaum gibt sowas ja schon. Bloß, da gibt es doch kein Clip.
Ja, willst du ja nicht da so... Klettband irgendwie an dein Hemd dran machen. Aber mit diesem Clip wär das natürlich super, dass du dann irgendwie so dein Logo hast, das leuchtet dann immer.
Wobei, das könnte man natürlich auch so machen, indem man einfach ein Foto drauf spielt, wo der Name drauf spielt. Malst du den Malprogramm, spielst du das per Alphot drüber?
Ja, das kommt jetzt nämlich. Und du stehst mir dann gegenüber und dann können wir über Bluetooth, machen wir dann einfach so Snip. Nimmst einfach so die Visitenkarte auf deinem Nano und snippst die so nach vorne.
Nee, man behält die so dran, dann springt man so mit der Brust an, Alter.
Ja, auf dem iPhone.
Und Hocker.
Ja, aber das sieht ja nicht... Gibt's das mittlerweile?
Na, für Hocker, oder?
Ja, Hocker macht das ja mit diesem Fangmisch.
Da gibt's genau dieses Rüberswipen, einfach so...
Ja, siehst du mal, da wäre doch der Nano eigentlich die optimale Plattform da für euch.
Ja, aber so richtig viel... Haut dich nicht vom Hocker. Nee, doch. Also, das kann ich mir echt gut vorstellen. Eigentlich wäre schon cool, z.B. Mails checken, Twitter...
Auf dem iPod Nano... Aber du hast doch keinen W-Lan und keinen 3G.
Du hast nix, ne?
Der hat kein Netz.
Wahrscheinlich gibt's jetzt noch die Nano-Sim, die dann in den iPod Nano reinpasst.
Ich bin mir sicher, es wird jemandem was Cooles einfallen, was man vielleicht haben wollen würde, und dann wird das Geschrei losgehen. Irgendjemand wird das Prototypen auf dem iPhone, sozusagen mit dem James-Brace.
Vor allen Dingen, was natürlich darauf brennen würde, theoretisch, ich weiß nicht, ob Apple da wirklich ein Interesse hätte, aber so als kleines Werbegeschenk für irgendwelche, zum Beispiel auf Konferenzen, wo dann noch das App drauf ist von dem entsprechenden Sponsor, wo du dir dann angucken kannst, was der alles so schickes gemacht hat. Und dann kannst du das noch als Namensschild nehmen.
Ja, also von daher ist halt, das kommt dann bestimmt beim iPod Nano.
Also kam gerade ein New Nano Not Running iOS According.
Was?
To rap at Demo Room, behauptet Gruber.
Aber was hat er? Er hat es doch gesagt. Oder täusche ich mich jetzt?
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass er es gesagt hat.
Ich dachte, er hat es gesagt.
Ach, das ist...
Was sagt Gruber? Gruber sagt, dass es kein iOS hat.
Also mich hat gerade jemand...
I don't believe it. Ich meine, dann müssten sie doch ihren ganzen... Dann müssten sie ihren ganzen Kack ja... Dann müssten sie dieses ganze User-Interface-Handling, das ganze Koko-Touch, müssten sie ja dann neu machen.
Man, die haben einfach zwei Gesten reinprogrammiert. Und ein bisschen Touch.
Ob man auf NetBSD portiert oder Linux oder was.
Da läuft kein iOS drauf, dass es kein App-Store gibt und dass es nicht iOS heißen darf.
Ja, das nennen sie nicht iOS, aber das ist im Kern das.
Das ist Darwin.
Ja, das ist Darwin, da ist Koko-Touch drauf und da läuft dann wahrscheinlich 90% des sonstigen Frameworks nicht und du hast kein IP und Pipapo, aber du hast halt den anderen Schnas.
Was das Ding für eine Auflösung hat, würde mich interessieren.
Audio-Freiber, ja, das würde mich auch interessieren.
Also, das steht euch in den Tech-Specs bestimmt. Display 240 x 240.
240 x 240. Und wie groß ist das?
1,54 Inch diagonal. Moment, wir haben es gleich hier. Wer ist schneller? Mein Dashboard lädt hier noch. Längst. Inch 1,54 sind 3,9 cm.
Ja, aber Diagonale sagt ja immer noch nichts aus.
Ja gut, dann machst du jetzt hier einmal Satz des Pythagoras, Piper Pore.
220 Pixel pro Inch.
Bitte?
220 Pixel pro Inch. Falls du das wissen wolltest, das steht noch unter den Daten.
220 Pixel pro Inch.
Stimmt, da steht es ja.
Also es ist ein wesentlicher, ein bisschen 1,2 Inch, also es ist ein 2,6, 2,7 cm x 2,7 cm Bildschirmfläche.
Oder 2,8.
Also das mit dem iOS, das werden wir die nächsten Tage noch rauskriegen. Also wenn es dafür einen Jailbreak gibt, wahrscheinlich über die PDF-Lücke, dann ähm...
3 cm, das muss ich mir mal so ein Ding hier mal so schneiden.
Also er ist breit 1 inch 61, das entspricht 4 cm. Also genau 4 x 4 cm, kann man schon mal sagen. Vom Gehäuse.
Und er hat diesen schwarzen Rahmen, den jetzt alles von Apple hat. Gibt es irgendein Apple-Gerät, das nicht um den Bildschirm herum so einen schwarzen Rahmen hat? Doch, das MacBook Air.
Und das MacBook ohne Glossy-Display.
Ja, okay, aber ich meine jetzt so Seriengeräte.
Der Mac Pro hat auch...
Ich hab schon von gesagt mit Bildschirm.
Na gut. Also sehr viel mehr können wir glaube ich nicht dazu sagen. Aber dass das Ding 24 Stunden Playtime hat, finde ich natürlich ganz cool, aber bestimmt nicht die ganze Zeit mit Bildschirm an. Aber dann muss ja dann auch Firma abspielen können und so.
Ja, diese Mini-Tour.
Aber war der Bildschirm nicht vorher größer?
Ja, glaube schon. Ja, ja.
Der war vorher 240x320 oder sowas.
Waren sich auf 3 cm so ein...
Obwohl der hatte sogar ein Hochformat.
Der war ja so richtig 16 zu 9.
Ich hab das dafür einfach niemand benutzt. Also ich hab das...
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Ich hab ein iPod Nano gehabt, der war super. Das war der beste iPod, den ich jemals hatte, weil so schön klein, konntest du in die Ecke fahren, aber ich hatte nie das Bedürfnis, Filme auf dem Ding zu gucken.
Naja, dafür kann man sich ja dann einen iPod Touch kaufen. Den gibt's jetzt auch in neu. Mit Rödeinord-Display und mit dem A4-Professor und mit dem Büro und überhaupt Kamera vorne, Kamera hinten und FaceTime. Mich hat gewundert, dass er jetzt nicht noch eine große FaceTime-Demo gemacht hat. Keine Ahnung warum, vielleicht kam es nicht so gut an.
Naja, also ist ja nur aus der Fail-Time jetzt mittlerweile eine FaceTime geworden. Benutzst du das?
Ja, ich benutze das.
Ich hab's noch nicht einmal benutzt. Ich möchte das nachher mal gerne ausprobieren mit irgendjemand hier.
Ja, du hast keine Kinder.
Soweit ich weiß nicht.
Das stimmt.
Das ist ein entscheidender Faktor bei dieser ganzen Geschichte. Den darf man nicht vergessen. Erinnere dich an den Werbespot.
Also der Grundraum ist noch nicht ausprobiert habe, weil ich noch niemanden jetzt auf die Nerven gehen wollte damit, so richtig, aber...
Du darfst mich ruhig mal an FaceTime.
Darf ich dich an FaceTime?
FacePalm.
Dann machen wir's mal.
Da kann man dann so seinen FacePalm austauschen.
FacePalm of the day, genau. Ja, also im Prinzip ein iPhone 4 ohne Phone.
Ja, aber volles Programm, ne? Aber mit Phone, weil da ist ja irgendwie FaceTime, ist ja VoIP drin.
Ohne 3G.
Und da ist ja dann auch Skype drin.
Skype ist auch drin.
Und mit Skype im Background ist so ein iPod Touch schon ein richtiges Skype-Telefon.
Und damit hält der Akku fast drei Minuten.
Hast du irgendwie Skype?
Skype auf iOS 4, das ist ganz unerträglich. Auch wenn das im Background läuft? Unglaublich, das ist unglaublich schnell, wie schnell der Akku damit leer wird. Also das ist wirklich so dieser berühmte Grund, so dieses, hey wir haben das hier eingebaut, bei Skype kann man sehen, nee es hat nicht funktioniert, trotz Abwohler.
Das kann daran liegen, dass natürlich dieses Skype-Modell, ich weiß nicht, wie die das auf diesem iPhone machen, aber ist das nicht so, dass die dann, machen die eigentlich noch dieses Ding mit Traffic für andere Leute auch noch mit über Trans?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, aber die Skype-Software auf dem iPhone, die ist unerträglich, die ist wirklich furchtbar. Da muss jemand sitzen, der keine Ahnung davon hat.
Oder die die Welt in Schmerz versetzt.
Also bei uns im Büro ist das so, dass wir, wir haben da so viele Gruppen-Chats. Und wenn ich Skype hin und wieder mal starte, Gruppen-Chats.
Das klang gerade noch was anderem.
Und was mach ich nochmal professionell? Und wenn ich das dann nach ein paar Tagen mal wieder aufmache, und das eben nicht mit der Grundlaufen hatte, weil es mir dann mein Akku leer sorgt, dann kann man wirklich zugucken, wie sich die Sprechblasen aufbauen. Dann dauert das so eine Sekunde pro Sprechblase ungefähr. Dann kannst du wirklich ungelogen eine Viertelstunde drauf warten, bis das Skype in einem Zustand ist, dass man es benutzen kann. Na so was ist natürlich nicht. Nee, nee, ganz furchtbar, will man nicht. Gerade kam noch per Twitter, hat kein GPS, der neue Apple Touch.
Das ist nicht verwunderlich. Weil ich mein, das Ding...
Wieso?
Weil bisher GPS immer nur mit GSM daher kam.
Weil das auf einer Platine oder auf einem Chip sitzt?
Gerade auch von der Usage her. Es gibt eigentlich so zwei Location-Modelle. Es gibt den WLAN-Location und es gibt den GSM-Zellen plus GPS-Kram.
Aber GPS finde ich echt in so einem Touch auch noch total sinnvoll. Weil du kannst ja halt irgendwie, wenn du nach Buchsehude fährst, kannst du hier vorher mit Offline-Maps schön irgendwie ganz Buchsehude runterladen. Dann läufst du mit GPS durch die Gegend und hast irgendwie Karten am Start.
Das ist doch sogar hier TomTom. Die bieten doch so eine Autohalterung an für diversen iOS-Geräte. Und die haben da noch mal eigenes GPS drin, sodass du mit deinem iPod Touch navigieren kannst. Ja, so verkehrt wär's nicht.
Aber andererseits, in der Stadt muss man sagen, ist das mit...
Ja, aber das Ding ist jetzt auch eine HD-Kamera. Das muss man jetzt auch mal sehen. Du kannst irgendwie... Was kostet das Teil in Deutschland? Deutscher Preis?
Deutscher Preis... Mach ich einen guten Preis, Watter.
Mach mir mal einen guten Preis, genau.
Ich mach dir einen guten Preis.
Das bedeutet natürlich, diese ganzen Flip und wie die nicht heißen, diese Flip-Geräte. Flip HD, genau, nicht 3D, sondern HD. Denen könnte das natürlich ganz ordentlich...
Also, der 8 GB iPod Touch kostet 229 Euro. Der 32, 299. Der 64, 399.
Unverbindliche Preisempfehlung. Gut, sagen wir mal, das mittlere Modell ist das Interessante. 300 Tacken, was zahlt man für eine gute HD-Kamera? Na gut, das ist eine Sache, die ist ja auch richtig objektiv.
Genau, also wenn du eine HD-Kamera für 300 Euro kaufst, dann ist das halt nur eine HD-Kamera und die ist für 300 Euro dann garantiert schon besser als das, was ich aus dieser Knopf-Augen-Kamera kriege.
Nee, mir geht es mehr so um eine immer-dabei-Cam. Aber klar, die haben natürlich dann irgendwie Optik. Ist schwer zu vergleichen, aber der Vorteil ist natürlich, du hast einen eigenen Teil und du hast fast alles drin, außer ein Telefon. Also es macht auf jeden Fall dieses Gerät als solches extrem viel interessanter, natürlich auch für Games. Und wenn sie eh schon so auf Games setzen, zu Recht, dann können sie natürlich damit...
Also die Zahl fand ich auch krass irgendwie mehr als Nintendo und Sony zusammen in Portable.
Ja, womit man sagen muss...
Du setzt dir jetzt das iPhone mit rein, oder?
Ist die Frage, ob der iPod Touch auch wirklich immer als Game-Konsole gekauft wird, ne? Also ob jetzt wirklich jeder kauft... Aber klar, für Developer ist das natürlich interessant. Die Ansage ist, hier, du hast einen Riesenmarkt, es gibt extrem viele Devices...
Also wenn die mal ankommen und sagen, so, jetzt hier Konami und... Wieso alle heißen die Evil Big Players mit den grauen Bärten? Dann wär das nochmal... Also ich mein, das ist halt schon so, dass irgendwie so die Killerspiele kommen ja immer noch so auf diese Nintendo, Xbox, PSP und so weiter raus. Nur so von Konami und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Von denen.
Das wird sich auch nicht von heut auf morgen ändern. Was hat Nintendo als letztes gemacht? Die haben diese Nintendo DS ja in dieser 3D-Variante rausgebracht. Keine Ahnung, wie gut das aussieht. Also sie haben da wirklich so ein Screen, der quasi für Augenabstand gemacht ist, sodass du da draufschaust und du hast einfach 3D. Also linker Auge sieht ein bisschen was anderes als rechter Auge und dann kannst du halt zwei Bilder liefern und dann hast du halt so richtig so 3D. Für so ein Teil, was du direkt vor der Nase hast, ist das eigentlich ein ganz geiler Ansatz. Von daher gehen die noch einen anderen Weg. Aber Apple ist das ja eigentlich auch ziemlich egal, was die machen. Sie haben einfach mit dem Game-Markt, kriegen sie jetzt so viele Leute ran und auch, dass jetzt hier endlich mal, muss man ja sagen, ja mittlerweile auch so eine Welle auf Mac einsetzt und so, das ist...
Aber Games auf dem Desktop sackt einfach immer noch und irgendwie, das ist jetzt ihr erstes Gerät nach so vielen Anläufen, wo, also wie oft die schon irgendwie mit Games irgendwie auf Keynotes erzählt haben, jetzt hier die neue Quake-Engine und was weiß ich alles.
Halo damals noch.
Oder ihr Pippen damals, ihre Spiele, die haben ja schon so oft versucht mit Spielen irgendwie Fuß zu fassen. Und jetzt haben sie irgendwie mal endlich ein Gerät scheinbar am Start, wo es so richtig rockt.
Und das ist ja fast versehentlich. Also das ist ja, ich könnte euch noch mal erinnern, als das so, naja, als irgendwann der iPod Touch wurde ja zuerst doch sehr stark als MP3-Player beworben. Und dann irgendwann sind sie extrem dazu übergegangen, dass das nur noch als Spiele-Teil zu bewerben. Und dann sind sie irgendwann direkt, haben sie direkt irgendwann gesagt, so, ja, ihr habt doch einen Taschencomputer von Apple, das ist hier der iPod Touch und das ist eigentlich so unser Taschencomputer. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig.
Wird denn auch eine Spielekonsole, die nur Spielekonsole ist? Überholt das Konzept eigentlich, ne?
Naja, ach, weiß ich nicht. Obwohl, bei der Spielekonsole... Ich hab auch noch so eine Nintendo Wii, die hat halt einfach ein Maß an Spezialisierung, das kriegen jetzt die anderen so nicht hin.
Na, jetzt langsam schon.
Dieser Controller und so, das ist einfach alles...
Das kommt zu Weihnachten, kommt das von den anderen auch alle?
Naja, wir werden sie auf jeden Fall... Auf jeden Fall sind sie gar nicht schlecht aufgestellt, jetzt auch bei Spielen, zumindest mobil.
Genau.
mobilespiele.de Und auch nicht so schlecht aufgestellt sind sie jetzt hier mit ihrem Ping, also mit ihrem Store, den sie jetzt in ein Social-Network verwandeln. Da-daaa! Also Last FM...
Wollen wir gleich mal Steve followen?
Was? Du followst Steve noch nicht? Ist der auf Ping?
Ja, er hat doch vorhin gezeigt.
Ist es schon da eigentlich, das iTunes?
Also was ich jetzt lustig fand, dass jetzt Apple eigentlich zwei Social Networks auf einmal angekündigt hat, oder? Also ich meine, so eins als dieses Ping und dann als Game Center noch.
Ja gut, also Game Center würde ich jetzt nicht als Social Network bezeichnen, zumal es ja derselbe Account ist.
Ja, aber ich meine, am Ende des Tages, also wo hast du jetzt überall deine Apple ID und du bezahlst immer mit deiner Apple ID über den ganzen Sachen so, dann irgendwie...
Und jetzt wächst das alles so nach und nach zusammen.
Jetzt kommt endlich zusammen, was zusammen gehört.
Die sind schon viel...
Ja, und die machen halt echt, also ich meine, Google, irgendwie kloppt dir überall Werbung rein und die kloppen dir einfach überall diesen Account rein mit deinem Wall-Click und...
Und die kloppen überall auf deine Kreditkarte drauf.
Die wohnen einfach direkt ab, so. Und nicht irgendwie hier drunter. Third-Party, App Provider, keine Ahnung, hast du nicht gesehen? Ja, nee, aber irgendwie ist die Tendenz ja schon, dass er da, also ich meine, sie haben sich ja von Skyhook Wireless ja emanzipiert. Also irgendwie schon das machen sie jetzt selber. Mobile Me haben sie sozusagen. Jetzt irgendwie eine Social-Network mit Followern. Also Facebook und Twitter meets iTunes. Und Game Center zusammen. Also die bauen sich da schon irgendwie ein fettes Online-Data-Center-Dingsbums zusammen.
Aber mit diesem Ping bin ich echt mal gespannt. Also ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das echt richtig in die Hose geht, weil so Mobile Me, das ist das richtige Stichwort, aber Lady Gaga hat damit geworben.
Mobile Me hat keiner mit geworben. Und Lady Gaga, den ist alle die Kleinen.
Meinst du nicht, dass Lady Gaga ihre Excel-Dokumente per Mobile Me verteilt?
Number-Dokumente, Mann.
Ich wollt jetzt noch so richtig schlecht raten.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, die haben das halt eh alle installiert, weil sie ihren iPod Touch und sonst was damit syncen müssen. Und man muss ja auch sagen, so was wie Last FM und so, die haben ja auch echt versagt jetzt. Also ich weiß ja gar nicht genau, woran das liegt. Aber zum Beispiel, guck mal, es gibt ja sowas wie Spotify. Spotify gibt es aber irgendwie nur in selected regions wegen Copyright, Fuba, Tra-la-la.
Weil die Verträge nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Musikstream.
Also Spotify ist iTunes in schnell in der Wolke. Das sieht super aus und so, macht Spaß.
Genau, aber gibt es nicht in Deutschland. Dann gibt es Last FM, aber Last FM hat irgendwie die letzten zwei Jahre massiv dafür gesorgt, dass es unbenutzbar wird. Du musst jetzt jeden Track einzeln. Es gibt nicht mehr für einen Artist eine ganze Playlist, die du durchhören kannst. Wahrscheinlich wegen Druck von außen. Die sind ja von Virgin jetzt, glaube ich.
Aber wahrscheinlich auch, um die Verträge aufrechtzuerhalten.
Genau, und Apple hat die halt schon alle im Boot.
Ob die Streaming-Verträge haben, da werden die bestimmt auch noch mal richtig zur Kasse gebeten.
Aber haben die nicht auch Hulu oder was war das? Die haben Lala?
Lala haben die gekauft. Ja, stimmt, die haben diesen Streaming-Dienst gekauft und denen soll noch nichts gemacht haben.
Genau, weißt du so, die haben noch Lala im Boot. Eigentlich so in der Hinterhand, also eigentlich riecht das so wie das irgendwie Last FM, MySpace, Spotify, alles jetzt mal richtig. Wir haben sie eh schon im Boot. Ihr habt hier einen One-Click-Button und so. Wir führen das jetzt mal alles so in einen heavy consumer Klumpalsch.
Na hat ja keiner gesagt, dass sie jetzt schon am Ende ihre Ankündigungen sind. Aber vielleicht noch mal dieses Ping. Also leider, der Stream war ja nun nicht gerade besonders toll. Zumindest bei uns gab es permanent Aussetzer. Später gab es Aussetzer. Und vorher gab es dann, genau als diese Ping-Vorführung war, hat er dann wieder auf davor geschaltet. Und wir haben wieder diesen Raum gesehen, wie er sich gefüllt hat.
Genau, wie irgendjemand so runter ging und total gewädelt hat, als ob er so, hey, ich bin im Fernsehen und er war im Fernsehen.
Unglaublich.
Und Reload hat es gebracht. Also so viel zum Thema Http, Streaming, Live-Test. Der ist ziemlich in die Hose gegangen für meinen Geschmack. Da kommen wir trotzdem nochmal drauf. Auf jeden Fall, Ping, finde ich einen ganz guten Namen. Ich habe jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden, was ist, aber wenn ich es richtig sehe, sie nehmen das Modell von Twitter, was die sozialen Verhältnisse betrifft, das Follower-Modell. Das finde ich eine sehr gute Idee, weil das ist der Grund, warum ich Twitter benutze und mich so unwohl fühle mit Facebook, mit diesem ganzen Freund-Quatsch, weil das funktioniert einfach nicht. Gerade nicht in so asymmetrischen Beziehungen wie Künstler und Fan. Andererseits haben sie aber auch Elemente von Facebook drin, dass du eben so eine übersichtliche Seite hast und antworten kannst auf, etc. und kommentieren kannst und wo du dann auch gleich die Filmchen und die Bilder so siehst. Gar nicht so schlecht. Und was sie ablösen, ist MySpace.
Auch und LastFM heißt.
Sie klauen sich sozusagen die Keyfeatures von Twitter und Facebook, um damit MySpace irgendwie vom Markt zu drängen.
Also wenn man da noch streamen kann, dann haben sie auch LastFM in der Tasche. Und hat jemand mal Lala angeklickt? Vielleicht ist ja das jetzt im Prinzip so ein re-written Lala. Aber nee, Lala hat gestreamt. Hieß das Lala? Diese Namen.
Naja, die anderen Domains waren alle schon weg.
Also was mir da ja wirklich echt mal so...
In fünf Jahren heißen die Start-ups nur noch irgendwie GBN 5, 63, 94.
Nee, die alle Unicode-Domains.
schneemännchen.com Followst du mir schon bei Tigerlily73?
Also iTunes-Update ist noch nicht da, aber es werden neue Geschäftsbedingungen gemacht. Erstens, die Geschäftsbedingungen werden gekürzt. Die Nutzungszene für die Upstore-Produkte wurden klarer formuliert. Und dann neue Bestimmungen zu Ping wurden in die iTunes-Store Geschäftsbedingungen eingefügt. Mit Ping wissen Sie immer, welche Musik Ihre Freunde und Lieblingskünstler hören. Was Sie sich anschauen und was Sie auf iTunes bereitstellen. Außerdem können Sie Ihre eigenen musikalischen Neuentdeckungen Ihren Freunden mitteilen. Wenn Sie Ping aktivieren, willigen Sie ein, dass wir die von Ihnen bereitgestellten Informationen und Informationen zu Ihren Aktivitäten auf dem iTunes-Store entsprechende Bestimmungen in diesen Geschäftsbedingungen anderen mitteilen können. Wenn Sie nicht wollen, dass Informationen über Sie von anderen eingesehen werden können, sollten Sie Ping nicht aktivieren.
Das klingt wie die diskordische Bibelstunde. Also so eine Ausschnitte draus.
Wiederstand ist zwecklos.
Aber was mir an Ping ja so ein bisschen Sorge macht, das ist ja quasi dann Social Network, was im iTunes läuft. Und das iTunes, was HTML-Darstellung angeht, ja nicht ganz so schnell wie Chrome oder sonstige WebKit-Browser, sondern irgendwie doch extrem langsam. Wird das jetzt bei diesem Ping auch so sein?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Haben die da jetzt dieses iTunes-XML-Modell dahinter? Das gibt es schon nicht mehr.
Der Store ist schon HTML.
Der Store ist schon komplett HTML. Der ist einfach nur noch so aus Spaß langsam.
Seit iTunes, was war das, 809?
Der ist langsam, weil iTunes langsam ist.
Ja.
iTunes OS.
Dann wird Ping jetzt wahrscheinlich auch langsam sein.
Natürlich.
Selbstverständlich.
Weil es ja 10 ist und nicht X.
Ob es wenigstens eine API gibt dafür, ob sie das machen werden?
Also mich verwundert das alles. Ich rechne nach wie vor, also ich denke mir, irgendwie muss es ihnen gelingen, all diesen ganzen Store-Klimbeln aus diesem iTunes heraus in die Browser-Sphäre, in die Web-App-Sphäre zu bringen. Und ich denke auch, dass sie das tun werden, aber sie warten eine Zeit ab, die so noch nicht gekommen ist, wo sich das Web und die nativen Applikationen irgendwie näher sind. Weißt du, näher als dieses, ich kriege so einen iTunes-Link an und dann sorgt mein Browser dafür, dass iTunes gestartet wird. Das muss irgendwie mehr Melange sein und muss irgendwie mehr zusammenhängen.
Ich hätte vor allen Dingen auch gerne einfach so einen Clean-Media-Player.
Genau, dann könnten sie das ja tun, wenn sie den ganzen Müll da mal rauskehren können und dann einfach so ein Player wie er bei iOS das sei.
Also es gibt halt echt auch Leute, ohne Scheiß, so Kollegen und so, die benutzen halt VLC als Media-Player, weil sie drängen sich die MP3s und so in die Playlist da rein, weil sie keinen Bock mehr auf so iTunes, irgendwie 3 GB RAM für weiß der Teufel was und ich will nur einen Pfeil abspielen, Jungs.
Ja, nachvollziehbar. Wir machen einen riesen Hack-Mac für nüscht.
Ja, da ist es ganz furchtbar.
Das geht gar nicht.
Und eben dieses Spinning Beach Boy auf Desk, der dich irgendwie alle paar Minuten davon abhält überhaupt was zu tun.
Auf Twitter wird mir gerade mitgeteilt, dass es sehr wohl Multifunktionsdrucker gibt von HP, die wohl sich auch voll integrieren. Da wurden auch Modelle genannt. Ich will das jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen.
HP sagt.
Bevor jetzt hier irgendwie, was das hier...
Die haben gerade Vepo S20 angekündigt.
Wir reden jetzt erstmal noch nicht von...
Reden wir doch erstmal von der kleinen schwarzen Kiste.
Kleine schwarze Kiste, das kleine schwarze... Nee, warte mal, stopp. Doch Ping, fällt mir noch was zu ein. Circle of Friends, hat er noch gesagt.
Gibt's da.
Freundeskreis heißt das doch auf Deutsch, oder? War das nicht so ein Combo?
Immer wenn es regnet.
Stimmt.
Immer wenn es regnet, muss ich mit dir Ping machen. Ping, Ping, Ping, Ping, Ping. Ich bin ehrlich gesagt immer noch so ein bisschen geschockt, weil, dass sie das jetzt wirklich durchdrücken. Jetzt weiß man noch, warum sie so viel Wert darauf gelegt haben, immer auf ihre 160 Millionen User zuzuhören. Wie viele hat Facebook?
500 Millionen. Das sind schon noch ein paar mehr.
Aber das ist schon, sagen wir mal...
So viel wie MySpace.
Ein ähnlicher, so viel wie Twitter.
Bei MySpace geht es da sicherlich gerade bergab.
Na ja, aber da sind es auch zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe, oder? Ich meine, auf der einen Seite hast du hier ein Musikgeschäft und auf der anderen Seite hast du...
Es gibt aber einen großen Unterschied zwischen den 500 Millionen Facebook-Usern und den 160 Millionen iTunes-Usern.
Dass die nämlich zu einem Großteil ihre Kreditkarten hinterlegt haben.
Ja, genau, die meisten. Fast alle.
Und die da bei allen Gelegenheiten auf Buy klicken können.
Ja, und das auch gerne tun, wenn ich meinen Portmanaser angucke oder meine Kreditkartenabrechnung.
Also MySpace hat 66 Millionen.
Aber hatten die nicht mal...
Das heißt, die sind aus dem Stand größer als MySpace.
Die haben doch irgendwann mal Zahlen genannt, wie viele Kreditkartennummern sie hinterlegt haben. Das war auch eine ziemlich beeindruckende Zahl, oder?
Na, das ist die Zahl.
Das sind 160 Millionen Leute, die sie haben.
Also es ist zwar irgendwie möglich, dir auch einen Account zu klicken, ohne eine Zahlungsgeschichte...
Wir brauchen gar nicht rumzuraten, weil irgendwann bei den letzten Kinos hat Steve Jobs gesagt, so und so viele Leute haben uns eine Kreditkarte hinterlegt. Und es waren verdammt viele.
Doch, alle User, die sie da haben, sind User mit Kreditkarten. Das war seine Aussage. Und die paar, die es geschafft haben, sich im Internet die Informationen zu holen, wie man ohne eine Kreditkarte zu hinterlegen, sich dein Account klickt, das ist ein Nerd.
Aber ich hab vier iTunes-Accounts, von denen einer Kreditkarten darunter legte.
Ja, du haust das, weil du dein Account auch irgendwie vorzeitig holst und irgendwie hackst und mit anderen Betrieben...
Damit ist klar, es ist...
Ja, es ist irrelevant. Wenn das nächste Mal einfach trocken Brot.
Nerds haben keinen Flatter.
Nerds flattern nicht.
Ich wollte nicht über Flatter reden. Ich wollte über...
Ping reden.
So, was das bedeutet. Ich frag mich jetzt zum Beispiel, also davon ist ja die Rede, dass Künstler können da irgendwie, also du kannst followen und gefollowed werden. Das heißt, du kannst, mit deinem Account hast du sozusagen automatisch eine Präsenz und Leute können dir folgen. Das heißt, das müsste dann auch für Podcasts da funktionieren.
Na dann mal schnell.
Das heißt, die Leute können auch sagen, dass sie Podcasts hören.
Dann kannst du auch Videos dazu hochstellen. Kannst du mal ein Video von deinem Studio machen. Oder ein paar Fotos, die du da reinstellst.
Kommt alles, kommt alles.
Musst du vorher mal den Beutel hier daneben.
Genau.
Die kannst du wegmachen. Na, siehst du mal.
Das werden wir sehen.
Wie viele Kreditkarten Facebook kennt.
2 Milliarden.
Dieses Ping-Ding startet nicht als Außenseiter, sondern ist sozusagen out of the box so gut gerüstet, dass es schnell zu einem der lebhafteren Netzwerke werden kann.
Ja, aber es kommt von jemanden, von einer Firma, die bisher noch keine großen Erfahrungen mit Social Networks hat und was ihre Außendarstellung angeht, um es jetzt mal positiv zu kauft.
Die Firma, die auch keine großen Erfahrungen mit Telefonen hatte, die keine große Erfahrung mit MP3-Playern hatte.
Ich glaube nicht.
Die haben ja Lala gekauft. Die haben eine andere bestimmt.
War denn Lala auch so ein Sozialklimb?
Ja, war glaube ich schon.
Ich dachte, das wäre so ein Streaming-Ding gewesen.
Ja, aber natürlich auch. Die machen von Anfang an keine Webseite an ohne irgendwie Freunde.
Ich hab das Lala nie getestet.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber wenn diese Elemente auch mit drin waren, kann das natürlich sehr wohl sein, dass aus Lala Pingen wurde. Und jetzt, dass Streaming noch mit dazu kommt, aber das ist nicht das wichtigste Ding. Das wichtigste Ding ist nicht, dass es streamt, sondern das wichtigste Ding ist, dass es netzt.
Netzt.
Darum geht's. Ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die musst du natürlich technisch im Griff haben, auf der anderen Seite musst du aber auch...
Du wirst deinen Ping benutzen und du wirst Leuten folgen. Du weißt, dass du das tun wirst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es benutzen werde. Ich meine den ganzen Tag über iTunes auf dem Rechner offen haben, um 140 zeichenlange Nachrichten zu empfangen. Hey, jetzt brauchen wir nur noch 6 Gigabyte.
Lala war eine Online-Musik-Store, die bei Silicon Valley-Entrepreneur Billy Nguyen gegründet wurde. Sie haben die Möglichkeit, Mitglieder online zu schenken, die schon als Radio-Stations bekannt waren, und ihre veröffentlichten Musik, die Volllangs-Songen für andere Lala-Members spielen können.
Für die nächsten Episoden werden wir Kursen in Englisch sprechen. Ich bin raus, weil ich habe ja vorhin auch vorgelebt.
Im Community-Forums.
Also Lala macht auch Sozial.
Mit anderen Worten.
Aus Lala wurde Ping.
Das Streaming fehlt noch.
Ping macht jetzt irgendwie...
Das Musikstreaming fehlt noch.
Das kommt.
Ich sagte, das kommt.
Ich glaube es auch.
Und dann halt noch...
Fernsehen.
Dann gab es noch Fernsehen. Apple TV gibt es jetzt auch in Viertelfund.
Komm so ran, komm so ran!
Hof, OfenTV-Bank und so. Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein... Wie sah das Ding aus? Das sah so ein bisschen aus wie so ein...
Freilingen-Packung?
Ja, so ein Dark Chocolate.
Mich hat es total an diese Western Digital Livebox erinnert, die ich auch noch zu Hause rumliegen habe. Die ist ungefähr genauso groß.
Das ist doch dieses tolle Teil, was alles kann, hab ich gehört.
Na, es kann Videos abspielen.
Ja, ja, ich war irgendwie... Das kann nicht. Ich glaube, hier Bits und so sind im Kreis gesprungen.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Also, wenn die Boxi-Box kommt, das wird nochmal spannend. Aber es ist...
Was haben sie weggelassen? Sie haben diesen ganzen analogen Output, den Komponent-Kram, weggelassen. Sondern sie gehen nur noch auf HDMI. Das Teil hat leider nur einen HDMI-Ausgang.
Wie viele hättest du denn gern?
Zwei.
Ausgänge? Um zwei Fernseher gleichzeitig betreiben zu können?
Einfach so aus Prinzip.
Ja, aber Apple geht es nicht um Nerd. Aber USB ist dabei.
Mikro-USB.
Mikro-USB? Mikro.
Oder Mini.
Also B oder C?
Ach man, auf jeden Fall verdammt klein. Also stand dran für Service und Sport.
Ich guck auf die Text-Band.
Ich glaube es war Mikro. Also es ist kein vollwertiger USB-Anschluss.
Das sind schon alles online hier.
Also Wireless hat da auf jeden Fall ein erressiver Mikro-USB vor Service und Support.
Das hieß, da heißt es durchlesen. Heißt mir richtig ein Werk.
Das heißt, du kannst dir Firmware-Updates da drüber brügeln.
Also wenn du dein Firmware-Update versaut hast, dann kannst du zum Apple Store gehen und kannst dir da ein neues drauf spielen lassen. Ich glaube das ist die Aussage. Und Jailbreak, klar, selbstverständlich.
Sieht auch... Ich lese hier gerade nochmal kurz die Tech-Specs.
Okay, ich auch.
Gut, dann kann ich so...
Ich rück nochmal kurz Pause im Spree. Eine 6 Watt Power Supply, 6 Watt, das ist ja nix.
Ist das denn schwarz?
Ja, das ist schwarz. Was hat das für ein Prozessor drin eigentlich?
Na, A4. Ich würde das überhaupt sagen.
Hat das dann auch iOS drauf?
Natürlich.
Weil das sieht ja doch so ein bisschen aus wie dieses alte...
Face it. Alles hat jetzt iOS drauf. Das ist einfach mal...
Es würde total viel Sinn machen.
Das geht jetzt los. Und ich will irgendwie eine Time Capsule haben. Die auch mal irgendwie damit.
Damit du da auch ein App Store drauf haben kannst. Also ich würde mir echt wünschen, ich meine, ich hab mir irgendwann mal so einen scheiß Apple TV gekauft. Ich hab's wirklich, wirklich bereut, dass ich da hier noch nicht mal den amerikanischen Preis, noch den deutschen Preis, der dann noch irgendwie... Ja, ich hab da so einen Apple TV zu Hause.
Und benutzt es auch?
Nie.
Nie?
Nie. Ich hab irgendwann den Stecker abgezogen, nachdem ich rausgekriegt habe, warum sich die Katze da so gerne draufsetzt. Nämlich, weil das so eine kleine Wärmplatte ist.
Das ist so ein Katzenwärmer.
Das ist so ein Katzenwärmer. Das ist das einzige, wofür man es wirklich gut gebrauchen kann.
Katzenwärmer mit USB-Anschluss.
Aber das ist wirklich die... Wenn man eine Katze besitzt, dann weiß man, wo die sitzt. Die sitzt auf dem Apple TV. Und ich hab dieses Ding, das war relativ teuer. Das hatte nur, hatte kein Full HD. Die Auswahl ist echt beschissen. Also so von wegen... Hätte ich da im Publikum gesessen, eben gerade während dieser Veranstaltung, als Steve gesagt hat, und die Kunden lieben mir Apple TV, die dies haben, dann wäre ich auf die Bühne gerannt und gesagt, nein, ich nicht. Ich hasse es. Und wenn sie es jetzt wenigstens so nachrücken, dass da diese neue Software draufläuft und ich wenigstens halbwegs billige Fernsehsälen streamen kann, dann wäre ich ja vielleicht so ein bisschen versöhnt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es gehen wird.
Warum nicht? Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da die neue Software im Sinne von, weil es hängt ja auch dieses Verleihmodell, dieses Kaufen zum Beispiel, damit dran, was es jetzt nicht mehr gibt. Also sie müssen diese Teile aktualisieren.
Sie haben eine große Basis.
Es kann aber sein, dass ein paar Features fehlen, zum Beispiel dieses Streaming. Aber das glaube ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Also dieses...
Doch, das ist da drin. Doch, das wird ein Update kommen.
Na hoffen wir mal. Weil nämlich ein Feature fand ich extrem schick. Und zwar dieses Videos vom iPad oder iPhone direkt auf das Apple TV rüber schicken.
Genau, Airplay, da müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch drauf zu sprechen kommen.
Habt ihr denn schon mal im iTunes-Store so Movies und TV-Serien gekauft?
Mit dem Apple TV oder generell?
Mich mit dem Apple TV auch mal.
Ich hab mir Lost The Final Season gekauft.
Ah ja, da hab ich auch ein paar Episoden. Das ist ja so eine der wenigen Inhalte gewesen, die auch auf Englisch überhaupt verfügbar waren.
Genau, und auch in Realtime verfügbar waren.
Das ist halt auch noch so eine Sache. Ich finde halt auch so, machen sie so ein iTunes-10-Update, also sie holen die 10 raus. Und da denkst du jetzt, wer wundert, was jetzt kommt für tolle Updates und Features. Und das Einzige, was sie echt bringen als Usability-Feature ist jetzt, alle 5 Spalten kommt jetzt in Cover Art. Also wenn du diesen Store benutzt, ich meine, wie bekloppt muss das auf dieser Apple TV sein, wo du wahrscheinlich überhaupt keine richtigen Filteroptionen hast, aber in diesem iTunes-Store kannst du ja irgendwie nicht suchen. Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist diese Web-Endlos-Groll-Dinger da durchklicken. Du kannst auf dem Listen-View gehen, aber du kannst zum Beispiel nicht sagen, ich will jetzt alles, was in Englisch verfügbar ist, alles, was rentable ist. So mit wenigen Klicks. Also, okay, Rentables haben sie, aber die Navigation in diesem Store ist total die Hölle.
Also Filme laden. Ich hab das jetzt auch schon mehrfach mir so gedacht. Ich sitze da so abends, weißt du? Und bevor ich jetzt in irgendeine bekloppte Videothek renne, um mir ein Medienzug kaufen will, dass ich keinen Abspieler habe, hole ich mir doch einfach so einen schönen HD-Film. Stöber ich da durch und dann erst mal so dieses Sprachenproblem, ich will keinen synchronisierten Kack haben und dann die fünf Filme, die irgendwie interessant sind, die werden dann nicht zum Mieten angeboten, sondern nur zum Kaufen.
Na das wird sich hier dann definitiv jetzt ändern.
Die sind da nicht mehr drin.
Und noch schlimmer, es gibt halt auch keine Subtitles, das finde ich auch ein bisschen peinlich eigentlich.
Das stimmt.
Also weil ich gucke zum Beispiel gerne englische Filme mit englischen Subtitles, weil wenn hier Vito Corleone, da kannst du halt englisch mitlesen. Und es gibt keine Subtitles, du kannst nicht nach diesen UV-Versionen suchen. Und was ich aber echt cool finde, so das Konzept, weil mir ist das auch klar geworden, du willst einfach nicht so einen digitalen Film kaufen. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, sich irgendwie so ein Pfeil zu kaufen.
Was du da nur auf der Platte rumlegen hast.
Einmal. So einen Film guckst du einmal. Also es gibt echt wenige Filme, die du öfter guckst. Und die Filme, die du öfter guckst, die guckst du nicht irgendwie 23 Mal im Jahr, sondern vielleicht alle drei Jahre mal nochmal. Und dann kannst du auch wirklich diese 1,99 Euro, die ihr da noch kostet, gerentet, irgendwie einfach mal klicken. Und dann ist er da. Weil statt in die Bibliothek zu rennen und da dann 3 Euro zu bezahlen, zu Hause auf dem Sofa sitzen, klicken und der Film ist da und peng.
Wenn sie fair wären, dann würden sie es ja so machen, dass du die ersten drei Male, wenn du dir so einen Film ausleihst, dass du dann quasi für zahlst und dass du dann irgendwann mal sagen, und jetzt darfst du sie so oft angucken, wie der Willstheoretiker schreibt. Also ich glaube, gerade Kinder, da kann Tim wahrscheinlich mehr von erzählen, ich glaube, die sind so, dass die einen und denselben Film zwölfmal am Tag gucken. Und wenn man dann sagen muss, nee, jetzt darfst du sie nochmal gucken.
Du kannst ja, wenn du einen Film gerentet hast, kannst du den ja innerhalb von 48 Stunden mehrfach gucken.
Ja, aber auch nicht nur am Tag, sondern die wollen das dann auch in der nächsten Woche noch sehen und so.
Anyway, auf jeden Fall bin ich Fan von diesem Rental-Modell und ich muss auch sagen, das was halt echt gut funktioniert, wenn du mal einen Film oder eine Serie gefunden hast, die du gucken willst an dem Store, was an dem deutschen Store echt schwierig ist, dann funktioniert das auch echt gut, dass das anfängt zu streamen und du wirklich ziemlich schnell, bevor der Film überhaupt zur Hälfte da ist, irgendwie schon gucken kannst. Also da muss ich sagen...
Ich hab mir da ein paar Mal Sachen gekauft. Ich glaub, ich hab mal eine Staffel Lady-Kracher gekauft. Ich hab's nie angeguckt.
Also ich hab mir schon zwei HD-Filme da gelegen und die waren echt so schnell, irgendwie konntest du dich hinsetzen, also wir saßen abends da, lange Weile, irgendwie, ahja, hier irgendwie, Don't mess with the Sohan, gibt's in Englisch ein HD-Los, lass mal klicken und du klickst und irgendwie zwei Minuten später kannst du schon anfangen zu gucken und das ist gut.
Also ich hab's ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gemacht, seitdem ich die 50 MBit-DSL habe, ich damals mit den 6 MBit, da war's ganz furchtbar. Für HD-Zweig war's echt...
Mit 16 geht's auch irgendwie innerhalb echt von 3 Minuten los.
Okay, also 50, das macht bestimmt Spaß oder so, 25. Also das Ding hat, würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall eine Chance, eine große Zukunft zu haben.
Na, wenn sie mehr Content da reinkriegen, endlich mal auch für die anderen Länder. Wenn sie ihr komisches Store-Interface da mal in den Griff kriegen. Also ich meine, es ist immer noch besser als so viel das andere da draußen. Aber ich weiß nicht.
Aber was...
iTunes sehen und dann ist da ein Social-Network drin und alle 5 Zeilen Cover-Art ist irgendwie... Ich bin noch ein bisschen enttäuscht, muss ich sagen. So eine Retrospektive.
Warten wir erstmal ab, wie das Ding dann performt. Hoffnung habe ich auch keine, aber jetzt will ich jetzt da abschließend so äußern, das ist natürlich auch Quark.
Aber was ich ja ganz spannend finde, wie gesagt, ist dieses Streaming vom iPad, also oder was auch immer, ist die Bildschirmausgabe vom iPad rüber auf dieses Gerät.
So, und was haben sie gesagt? Sie haben gesagt, dass sie iTunes umbenennen in Airplay. Das heißt wiederum auch, dass eigentlich die Airpod Express in dem Sinne kompatibel bleiben müsste.
Also ob die Airpod Express, das weiß ich nicht, aber irgendwann stand das Ding TimeCaptainable kompatibel zu dem Apple TV.
Ich meine, das ist das Einzige, was der jetzt halt eher für uns macht, sind die Express. Stimmt.
Und das Apple TV.
Und das Apple TV kann, wie war das, kann mittlerweile, glaube ich, sowohl als Ziel, als auch als Sender fungieren. Das habe ich nämlich jetzt noch selber, doch einmal habe ich das ausprobiert, weiß ich jetzt nicht, habe halt so einen Teil nicht, deswegen weiß ich es gerade nicht. Aber so oder so, im Wesentlichen hängt das immer noch da dran. Und das ist halt kein offenes, unbekanntes Protokoll bisher gewesen. Sie schicken meine Erkenntnis nach entweder AAC oder Apple, das ist noch gleich an, das Ankompress.
Und Ruck am Möber hat das lizenziert, oder wie?
Ja, also reverse-ingeniert hat es, warte mal, wie heißt denn bitte nochmal gleich dieses Apple...
Apple Lossless?
Apple Lossless, genau. Das können sie auch. Und schickst du es halt irgendwie rüber, dann spielt es ab und dann kann es sich irgendwie sinken mit diesen Teilen, sodass du eben auch in mehrere Räume schicken kannst. Du kannst von Raum zu Raum laufen und du hast mehr oder weniger seamless... Also wenn die Räume nicht selbst in sich hinein heilen, dann hast du natürlich wieder Laufzeitverzögerungen, aber sie schaffen es halt, den Delay auszumessen und das iTunes schickt das hin. Bloß du kannst halt vom Mac eigentlich nur von iTunes aussenden. Du kannst selber nicht als Empfänger für einen iTunes dienen, wenn du nicht selber irgendwie eine Airport Express Station bist. Warum? Weil sie da Krypto machen und irgendwie so einen Key haben und den hat hier Mr. DVD-John, der DVD-Knacker. Der hat das Teil mal rausgefunden, diesen Key, der in dieser Express ist. Und deswegen kann man jetzt eben auch mit anderen Programmen, Rook Amoeba, Airfoil, dahinschicken. Aber Rook Amoeba hat auch kein Produkt, was so ist wie ein iTunes. Es gibt kein anderes Programm, was sich anmeldet und sagt, ich bin ein iTunes und was von einem iTunes erkannt wird.
Nicht? Ich dachte genau das tun sie.
Nein, da haben sie ein eigenes Protokoll, ihr Airfoil-Kram und dazu musst du halt die Airfoil-Software auf deinem Rechner haben, was du dann eh willst, weil du dann natürlich auch gleich diesen anderen Schnaß mit drin hast, mit Capture, den Output von deinem Safari und schick den irgendwo hin. Sie haben halt dann auch auf dem iPhone gibt es dann halt diese Airfoil-Speaker-Software und die gibt es auch für den Mac. Also sie haben sozusagen ihre eigene Infrastruktur, aber diese iTunes-Geschichte ist halt nochmal separat. Und während es mittlerweile so weit gehackt ist, dass das zwar jeder zu einer Airport Express senden kann, kann bislang niemand als Empfänger agieren, der nicht Apple ist. Und dadurch ist dieses ganze Modell, finde ich, auch schon immer sinnlos begrenzt gewesen. Jetzt sagen sie, aus AirTunes wird AirPlay und sie machen auch Video und sie machen Streaming. Jetzt versuchen wir mal ein bisschen eins und eins zusammen zu zählen. Wovon redet Apple seit Jahren? Mit dem ganzen Streaming, also was heißt seit Jahren? Seit wann reden sie jetzt davon? Seit 10... 6. Genau, mit 10.6 kam das doch. Das war TTP-Streaming.
Ach so.
Und alles, was sie machen, auch diese Live-Stream, auch wenn da heute so ein bisschen ein Fail war, keine Ahnung, da ist ihnen irgendwas... Irgendwas hat nicht geklappt, ich kann es nicht sagen, aber das habe ich schon mal besser gesehen. Aber das war der erste Event, den sie nicht mit RTSP gestreamt haben.
Und der erste Event seit langem überhaupt, den sie überhaupt gestreamt haben.
War das auch der erste in HTML5, oder was?
Ne, das war Flash.
Das kann gut sein. Das habe ich jetzt gar nicht drauf geachtet. Das nehme ich sogar an, das war auf jeden Fall nicht Flash. Und HTTB-Streaming, das habe ich mir mal genauer angeschaut, das ist an sich eine sehr einfache Geschichte, du kannst dann Videocontent und Audiocontent-Streaming vorrätig halten, also zum Konsumieren über Streaming. Man muss immer unterscheiden, Streaming und Live-Streaming. In diesem Fall war es ein Live-Streaming. Das heißt, du brauchst halt ein Setup, das dieses Video- und Tonbild dann auch in Echtzeit bereitstellt. Aber der Konsum funktioniert von der kleinen Seite her immer identisch. Und zwar sind das einfach HTTP-Requests. Und das erste, was der Client macht, ist, er geht auf diesen Server und holt sich ein Playlist-File. Das ist die eigentliche Adresse. Und das ist tatsächlich so ein Playlist-File, wie man das eben aus dieser MP3-Streaming-Welt kennt.
Zum PLS-Think.
Genau.
Ist auch so ähnlich aufgebaut. Bloß halt noch mit ein paar extra Keywords, die von Apple dann definiert wurden und die sie auch als AETF-Standard vorgeschlagen haben. Also das ist jetzt nicht proprietärer Scheiß. Das ist nur so, dass Apple damit eben aufgekommen ist. Und sie hoffen halt, dass es adoptiert wird. Adobe macht sowas Ähnliches mit ihrem RTFM, wie heißt das? Es ist schon so spät, wie auch immer, ihr wisst schon. Das, was Flash macht und Microsoft mit ihrem Silverlight hat auch ein ähnliches Modell, die sie alle so ein bisschen unterscheiden. Apple macht es halt so. Und du holst halt diese Playlist und da stehen dann immer so die nächsten Chunks drin. In der Regel so 5-10 Sekunden, das kannst du selber festlegen. Und du musst halt den ganzen Kram in MPEG Transport Stream Format vorliegen haben. Das heißt, Transport Stream ist so, wie es vom Satelliten kommt. Das ist halt nicht ein MP4-Container, sondern es ist eben MPEG Transport Stream. Und dann lieferst du eben diese Chunks aus und der Client baut sich das irgendwie selber zusammen. Das heißt wiederum auch, wenn du nicht live bist, sondern du hast die Recording schon liegen, brauchst du gar keinen speziellen Streaming-Server mehr. Du kannst einen normalen HTTP-Server nehmen und legst dann einfach deine Chunks da drauf. Die heißen alle irgendwie. Und dann musst du nur noch Playlist-Files rausliefern, wo dann sozusagen drin steht.
Von da bis da.
Genau, der erste ist der, der zweite ist der und dann heißen die irgendwie mit Zeit oder was auch immer. Und dann kannst du da eben beliebig drin hin und her scrubben und zurückspringen und diesen ganzen Foo machen. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist folgendes. Es ist einfach schon immer Apples Art gewesen, dass sie die Anzahl der Technologien, die sie so insgesamt zum Einsatz bringen, reduziert halten. Wenn sie jetzt sagen, wir machen jetzt Streaming und wir nennen das Airplay und wir machen es zwischen unserem neuen Apple TV, wo iOS draufläuft, dasselbe OS, was auf iPhone läuft und auf dem iPad läuft und das Einzige, was es da gibt, ist auch nur dieses HTTP-Streaming, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendetwas anderes ist, als dieses HTTP-Streaming. Das ist einfach das, was sie da tun.
Mit DHM allerdings versehen.
Das, nee, da ist erstmal gar kein DHM dabei.
Nervös Fernsehsälen, wenn du die streamst. Da würden doch alle schreien vor Begeisterung, wenn du einfach den Sniffer anschmeißen müsstest und dann den Stream aus der Luft fangen könntest. Dann ist das auf deiner Platte drauf. Da würde doch die Content-Industrie gar nicht mitspielen.
Meines Wissens gibt es da derzeit keinen DHM in dieser ganzen Spezifikation so drin. Du kannst Verschlüsselungen angeben, du kannst einen Key mitliefern, der dann in dieser Playlist mit drin steht, sodass Over-the-Earth schon verschlüsselt ist und du dann sozusagen sicherstellen musst, dass du die Playlist über einen sicheren Kanal holst. Also du könntest dir die Playlist über HTTPS holen mit irgendwie Credentials, mit Login, was ja in diesem Apple TV sehr wohl der Fall sein wird. Der holt sich das bei dem Store so und das kann auch sehr wohl sein, dass das entkryptet übertragen wird. Das kann sein. Also es ist entkryptet so und die AM machen sie ja dann wiederum mit dem HDCP. Das müssen sie ja machen. Lass mal das erstmal raus.
HDCP zu HDMI meinst du?
Genau.
Und eben genau, über HDMI beziehungsweise wie sie es hier auf dem Mac ja dann auch mit den Bildschirmen machen etc. Und das wollen sie nicht machen, aber das müssen sie machen.
Keine Ahnung, ob sie das wollen, sie machen es.
Steve Jobs hat neulich auf dieser Konferenz gesagt, dass sie das, wie sagte er so schön, zu der Person, die gefragt hat, I can feel your pain. Also, kurze Zusammenfassung nochmal von dem, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte. Ich glaube, dass sie auf HTTP-Streaming gehen. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass ihr Airplay, so wie sie das jetzt pushen und wie sie das angekündigt haben für iOS 4.2, auch auf HTTP-Streaming basiert. Das heißt, es ist so offen, dass man da eben nicht mehr diese Kette hat, wie jetzt, mit diesem blöden Airport-Express-Scheiß, sondern du kannst beide Seiten implementieren. Du kannst zu einem iPad schicken, du kannst zu einem Apple TV schicken und du kannst selber auch empfangen.
Dann ist da DRM drauf. Zumindest für ihr Serienzeug und für die Musik und so was. Also für Musik nicht, aber für Serien.
Aber wenn du von deinem iTunes in deinem Apple-TV-Streams hast, hast du doch da kein DRM drauf.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt hier auf meinem iPad mir eine Serie ausleihen könnte und selber einen Client quasi dafür implementieren könnte, mit dem ich das nur noch weggraben brauche, da ist da irgendwie... Du meintest doch, wenn das ein offener Standard ist.
Ich rede jetzt nur von diesem Streaming. Ich rede nicht von dem Content des Stores. Ich rede nur von der Technologie-Streaming zwischen den Geräten. Das, was sie für iOS angekündigt haben. Und was in diesem Apple TV drin ist. Und das kann von deinem Mac aus dahin streamen. Und ich sage dir, dieses iTunes 10 schickt das mit HTTP-Streaming dahin.
Das mag sein, aber da ist noch irgendein Verschlüsselungsstandard drauf.
Wir werden sehen.
Das werden wir sehen, aber ansonsten wäre es dir ja immer gebrochen.
Ich rede von Files auf deinem Computer. Wozu brauchst du kein DRM drauf? Wenn dieser File ein Film ist, den du gerade vorher gekauft hast, ich rede nicht von gekauften Content. Ich rede von irgendeinem Content. Von deinem iPhone Video, was du von deinen nicht existenten Kindern gedreht hast.
Das hast du dann auf deinem iTunes. Guck mal, sie haben es doch gezeigt, wie er auf seinem iPad hier irgendwie abkupft.
Okay, lass mich anders ausdrücken, was ich eigentlich sagen will. Du kannst Software machen, die zu deinem Apple TV streamt. Du bist nicht abhängig von iTunes. Jeder kann abschreiben, was dahin streamt. Wir werden einfach Software sehen auf diesem Markt, was dieses Apple TV benutzt, um es auf dem Fernseher anzuzeigen.
Kann man jetzt eigentlich schon...
VNC Klein, dann kann man ihn als 2.
Kann man denn schon Keynote eigentlich auf einem Apple TV streamen?
Das wäre nämlich tatsächlich, würde ich mal sagen, eine spannende Sache.
Weil so eine Sache halt.
Weil das, was er jetzt gezeigt hat mit dem iPad und dem Video rüber streamen, da habe ich mich gefragt, das sieht vom Interface her so ein bisschen so aus, als ob man hier dieses VGA-Kabel dranhängt am iPad. Und das wäre doch eigentlich eine logische Sache, dass man dann auch Keynote darüber bedienen kann. Und für Keynote würde das natürlich auch total viel Sinn machen, weil wenn Keynote HTTPS-Streaming unterstützen würde. Nee, es kann ja sein, dass das iPad, guck mal, das iPad hat eine AP drin, um externe Monitore oder externe Displays anzusprechen. Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist... Du kannst da externe Dinger dran machen.
Weil das Teil eine VGA-Logik hat.
Ja, aber das ist, was mir nämlich massiv aufgefallen ist, dass all diese Sachen, alles womit du das nutzt, unglaublich laggt. Ich hab probiert, einfach einen Webbrowser zu kriegen, mit dem man auch Fernsehern zeigen kann.
Du hast diesen Adapter.
Ich hab dieses Adapter-Kabel, hab ich zu Hause, hab da ein VGA-Kabel dran, hab das an meinem Fernseher dran. Dachte jetzt, okay, jetzt kauf ich mir so ein Web... Safari da drinnen kann das nicht. Safari da drinnen kann ich mit einem VGA-Monitor umgehen. So, jetzt hab ich mir diverse Browser gekauft, die das alle können. So, die kosten also jeweils 1.250 oder sowas. Browser gekauft?
Das hören wir auch nicht an.
Die das auf dem VGA-Bildschirm können. Welche können das? Das sind furchtbare Teile, die ganz furchtbar aussehen. iCAP kann es nicht. Das sind nur ein paar. Die haben dann speziell etwas dafür implementiert. Die leggen alle unglaublich. Es ist nicht so, dass die einfach ein Mirroring des internen Monitors machen. Das gibt es nur über Sydia. Die müssen offensichtlich speziell mit kommunizieren, mit diesen externen Boxen. Ich hab mich gefragt, warum? Entweder du hast da einen zweiten Monitor dran, dann sollte das schön schnell sein. Da wäre jetzt eigentlich der Schluss nahe, dass das schon darauf vorbereitet ist, dass das auch irgendwann mal über Wi-Fi geht an so eine Apple TV Box und dass alles, was bisher so ein VGA-Adapter benötigte, in Zukunft dann auch mit einem Apple TV umgehen kann. Mit einer kleinen Änderung.
Verstehe, was du meinst.
Das war so der Gedanke.
Du meinst, das ist ein virtueller Screen, der sich dann sozusagen da so einblendet, und es egal ist, ob man VGA entschließt oder...
Genau. Und für Keynote würde es auf jeden Fall Sinn machen. Und für iTeleport würde es auch Sinn machen.
Kleiner Eingriff zwischendurch.
Ja.
Die Epic Citadel Demo gibt es als Gratis-App auch am iTunes Store schon.
Ach hier, dieses Teil, was sie da gezeigt haben.
Ja, das ist aber wohl nur so die Demo von dem Level. Also es gibt wohl... Sofort spielen, ja.
Soll ich nochmal das... Ich besitze jetzt...
Das sah sehr schick aus, fand ich.
Das sah beeindruckend schick aus. Mal sehen, wie es jetzt in echt aussieht.
Ach, bitte.
Hast du über deinen GSM eingeschaltet?
Hm, Entschuldigung. Ich habe übrigens eine tolle Methode gefunden, wie man die Sache mit den Foldern hier übersichtlich gestalten kann. Zumindest bilde ich mir das ein, dass ich eine tolle Methode gefunden habe.
Und zwar?
Kennt ihr dieses Problem? Eigentlich wollt ihr alles in Folder reinpacken und dann tut ihr das und dann findet ihr, ihr könnt diese Folder nicht mehr wiedererkennen, weil das alles nur noch so kleinkariertes Zeug ist. Ja, ja, auch ein Retina-Display.
Kenn ich das Problem, ja.
Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist, also ein Folder bestimmt sich bei mir aus die Dinge, die da reingehören, und dann das eine Programm, was so exemplarisch ist für diesen Folder, wie nur irgendwie geht, oder was sozusagen das ist, was ich am häufigsten davon benutze.
Das schiebst du dann ganz nach vorne?
Nee, das lege ich daneben. Das heißt, das nehme ich wieder aus dem Folder raus und ich habe sozusagen das Programm und daneben die anderen. Also zum Beispiel habe ich ein Folder.
Jetzt kichert es dir nicht über mich.
Jetzt wissen wir endlich mal, wofür das Retina-Display gut ist, um das iTunes-AGBs anzuzeigen.
Leute, das ist ein Audiopodcast. Ihr könnt euch hier nicht gegenseitig eure Pornbilder auf dem iPhone zeigen und kichern.
Also ich habe hier gerade die iTunes-AGBs mit 58 Seiten auf 3 Punkt Größe.
Ich erkläre gerade was.
Also du warst gerade bei den Folder-Prinzipen.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt mal. Ich muss euch ja da abholen, wo ihr steht.
Pornbilder und Abholen, wo wir stehen, ist ja auch lustig.
Funktioniert auf jeden Fall sehr gut. Ich habe hier zum Beispiel einen Ordner, der heißt Chat und SMS. Und da sind halt so diese ganzen Sachen, die halt irgendwie mit Twitter und mit IRC und so weiter zu tun haben. Und die Twitter-App, die ich halt benutze, Premiere, die liegt halt daneben und so weiter. Oder Maps. Und daneben gibt es einen Folder, der heißt Outdoor. Und da ist irgendwie der ganze Kram drin. Nur so als Tipp, vielleicht interessiert es ja jemanden.
Ich benutze ja keine Folder.
Ja, vielleicht jetzt schon, nicht wahr?
Nee, ich mach... Hab ich letztes Mal schon gesagt, ich benutze die Folder nur für die Apple Apps, die vor uns sind.
Ich wollte ja auch eigentlich nur die Zeit stricken, bis ihr alle euren Demo-Level runtergeladen habt, damit das hier die Sendung nicht stört. Konntet ihr nicht wissen, dass wir uns gleich wieder anzicken?
Ich muss erst mal hier 58 Seiten iTunes-AGB auf dem iPhone brauchen. Was kann ich denn dafür? Das braucht halt seine Zeit.
Aber wie wird wohl in Zukunft das iPodeiken auf dem iPhone aussehen, wenn es jetzt nicht mal mehr ein Gerät gibt, was so aussieht, wie dieses iPhone, was da drauf ist? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Bei mir hat jetzt sogar das iPodeiken unten links, das ist jetzt in einen Ordner gewandert, und zwar mit dem Programm iSub. Heißt das? Weil ich hab in New Revers auf meinem Linux-Server installiert. Und das heißt Subsonic. Und das ist so eine kleine, sehr hässliche Java-Software. Mit der man seine MP3s hochladen kann und die die dann irgendwie verwaltet. Mit einer gewissen Podcast-Unterstützung, die gar nicht mal schlecht ist. Und damit kann ich mir meine Musik endlich, endlich, endlich auf das iPhone streamen. Über 3G. Und ich brauch nicht mehr, wenn hier irgendwie eine neue Podcast-Folge da ist. Und ich bin gerade durch Zufall aus der Entfernung eines WLANs und diese Podcast-Folge ist nun dummerweise ein CRE mit 153 Megabit. Dann kann ich das in Zukunft trotzdem laden, obwohl ich nicht im WLAN drinne bin.
Zu groß sind unsere Podcasts.
Und ich kann meine gigantische Musiksalonung nicht mehr auf dieses iPhone drauf zu kopieren, sondern hab sie irgendwo auf meinem Server bei Hetzner herumliegen.
iSub.
Genau.
Aber das wär doch auch so eine Sache. Du lädst das dann einfach alles bei Ping hoch und dann streamst du dir das von deinem Ping-Account.
Ja, das wär natürlich sowieso super. Da hätt ich mir gedacht, wenn die Musikindustrie halbwegs schlau wäre, dann hätte sie das schon vor Jahren gemacht. So ein Ding, wo du deine Musik hochladen kannst. Ähm, nee, ich kann dir mal zeigen, wie das Icon aussieht. Das sieht so aus wie so ein gelbes U-Boot, was so vorne zwei Wellen drauf ist. Genau.
Da hatten sie jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade alle diese Epic-Demo runter, das kriecht hier nur so aufs Phone.
Wie heißt denn diese Demo, genau? Citadel. 3,99 kostet der Music Streamer.
Ich muss noch von was leben.
Nee, ist ja in Ordnung. Wenn's funktionieren will. Ich bin ja pro kaufen.
Also es ist nicht perfekt. Ich glaube, Tim hätte da auch einiges zu meckern. Was leider total scheiße ist, ist die Podcast-Unterstützung von diesem Client. Aber die von dem Server ist gut. Da kann man nämlich wirklich eine Podcast-URL reinschmeißen und dann guckt der alle halbe Stunde nach, ob eine neue Folge da ist und lädt die dann im Hintergrund runter. Du kannst sagen, wie viele Folgen möchtest du gern behalten und wie verletzt du gern. Und so scheint ein relativ intelligentes Management zu haben, was das Caching angeht. Also du kannst sagen, hier nimm dir 5 Gigabyte und cache da meine Dateien rein. Weil bei Musik ist es ja doch so, dass man häufiger mal dasselbe hört, dass man gar nicht so eine große Musiksammlung die ganze Zeit bei sich haben möchte. Das macht mir alles schon relativ durchdachten Eindruck.
Und dann machst du halt den Playback mit dieser Applikation sozusagen, weil das ja alles eben in dieser Applikation liegt und eben nicht im sonstigen.
Genau. Und es ist total iOS 4-kompatibel. Weil man kann im Hintergrund spielen, die Musik und sowas, also so wie man es haben möchte eigentlich.
Nur, dass diese Funktionalität noch nicht so ist, wie man sie haben möchte. Wenn man einmal stoppt, dann ist es gleich komplett beendet.
Der Desktop-Client ist noch besser, Adobe Air. Aber es gibt auch, man kann es auch im Webbrowser laufen lassen.
So ein Undercover-Agent bist du.
Der hat dann von etwas Positives über Adobe gesagt. Oder was nicht Negatives. Wer hat Adobe in Schutz genommen? So war es. Noch schlimmer.
Ich weiß nicht, wer?
Nein, das kann ich jetzt nicht in Schutz nehmen.
Sowas würde ich niemals tun.
Es war nur eine beiläufige Erwähnung des Firmen.
Für Oracle-Software geschriebene...
Komm, wir bleiben jetzt mal bei unserer Themenlinie.
Ja, das kann ich nur empfehlen. Macht echt Spaß.
Okay, wir reden jetzt noch ein bisschen über iOS und iPhone-Kram. Also wir sind mit dieser Keynote durch oder haben irgendwas vergessen? Dieses Gesinge am Schluss müssen wir wohl nicht kommentieren, oder? Ich hab bei meinem iPad ein bisschen mit Flipbook rumgeflippt.
Achso, das ist diese...
Hast du das ausprobiert?
Selbstverständlich. Das ist diese Software... Flipbook oder Flipboard? Meinst du dieses Twitter, Facebook... Ich geh mir meine eigene Zeitung. Flipboard heißt das.
Das heißt Board.
Board. Also das ist ja dieses rote F, ne?
Genau, das heißt Flipboard. Entschuldigung, nicht Flipbook. Ja, aber ich weiß, das ist ausstehend. Jetzt kommt Facebook auch noch, wenn sie sich irgendwie Book irgendwie sichern. Das hab ich ja heute irgendwo gelesen, dass sie irgendjemanden verklagen, Teach Book.
Genau.
Weil sie auch auf Book enden und dann stand noch dabei, dass sie auch Face irgendwie als Marke eintragen wollen.
Das Face brauchen wir in Zukunft auch.
Da kann man echt glücklich sein, dass sie nicht Palm gekauft haben.
Stell dir vor, irgendeine Firma würde noch die Rechte auf die Farbe Rosa haben wollen.
Das wäre ein Spaß. Sowas kann man sich ja nicht vorstellen.
Das wird niemals passieren.
Flipboard, also an sich eine schöne Sache und ich glaube, das wird auch, das wird irgendwie kommen, das wird irgendwie etwas sein, was man auch in mehreren Anwendungen sieht. Es gibt auch schon ein paar andere, die es ähnlich machen. Dieses Times, dieser Times-RSS-Rider macht ja einen ähnlichen Ansatz.
Zwei, neun Sterne.
Dieses, ich formatier dir alles hübsch, so wie du es von einem Magazin-Layout kennst. Das ist an sich eine schicke Sache.
Das zeigst du nicht danach darüber.
Na ja, Times.
Nee, das ist nicht Times.
Okay, gut. Ja, ist eine schöne Idee. Ich kann noch nicht sehr viel mehr zu sagen. Das Flipboard, das auf jeden Fall werde ich mal ausprobieren. Als ich das runtergeladen habe, waren sie mir total überladen und es dauerte zwei Wochen, bis sie mir dann mal erlaubt haben, meine Twitter-Timeline da einzugeben.
Ich hatte noch Glück, ich war so früh dabei, dass es noch relativ schnell geklatscht hat.
Sie möchten halt das Passwort haben, das finde ich ein bisschen in Zeiten von O aus und so weiter. Sollte es ja auch andere Möglichkeiten geben, das zu machen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber habe ich ihnen trotzdem gegeben. So bin ich.
Och, du bist ja nett. Ich war ein großer Freund von Instapaper auf dem iPad. Instapaper, kennt ihr das? Offline Reading. Genau, Offline Reading. Das hat so ein schönes, reduziertes Layout. Man hat nicht diese ganze Werbung drum herum und so was.
So ein bisschen wie dieser Safari-Reader-Modus.
Genau. Und jetzt bin ich kein Fan mehr von Instapaper, weil ich nämlich Read It Later gesehen habe. Read It Later ist eigentlich exakt dasselbe wie Instapaper, außer dass die sich etwas deutlich mehr Mühe geben. Also das ist...
In der App.
In der App, in allem. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass das Runterladen von Artikeln geht wesentlich schneller. Und was die noch haben, was ist dabei, oder es ist nicht dabei, sondern das muss ich extra dazu kaufen, nochmal für 3,99 Dollar, das ist dieser Digest-Modus. Und damit arbeiten die deine zurückgelegten Artikel wirklich so ein bisschen wie so eine Zeitung auf. Die schaffen das tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht nach welchen Standards, das hab ich noch nicht rausgekriegt, die in Kategorien so Technology, Programming, Mobile Science, Apple, was weiß ich was, einzusortieren. Das schaffen sie auch mit deutschen Artikeln. Also ich weiß noch nicht so genau, wie sie das hinkriegen. Und dann hat man das da so ein bisschen präsentiert, das ist echt süß gemacht. Und die App bietet so Dinge wie einfaches Umschalten zwischen schwarz auf weiß und weiß auf schwarz für Text und sowas alles. Und hat unten, was ich echt schön gemacht finde, was ich bis vor 28 Sekunden dachte oder bis ich es gesehen habe, dass es Apple vorbehalten war, dass es so eine Appie sei, wenn man hier unten den Finger drauflegt, dann hat man so einen Balken, mit dem man die Helligkeit einstellen kann. Und das ist so total praktisch, wenn man so liest im Bett abends und dann will man mal rasch die Helligkeit nachjustieren und dann hält man einfach kurz den Finger gedrückt und super, jetzt klappt es natürlich, ich brauche mich hier nicht mehr als Vorführeffekt.
Ich habe es gesehen. Und Kramme können das jetzt machen, ohne gleich aus dem Appstore geschmissen zu schmissen. Ist das jetzt offiziell, diese Appie?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wie nennen Sie das so in Software?
Es kann auch sein, dass Sie das einfach auf Ihren, dass Sie gar nicht die Helligkeit des Kriegs, sondern die Helligkeit des gesamten angezeigten Innern.
Die Status-Leiste wird zumindest mit dunkel. Wobei, die scheinen sie auch ein bisschen im Griff zu haben, weil ich glaube, da tauchen auch noch zusätzliche Features auf. Aber es sieht schon so aus, als ob das ganze Display...
Du kannst das ganz einfach überprüfen, weil wenn du rausgehst aus dem Programm, müsste ja dieses Setting dann erhalten bleiben.
Nee, da ist es wieder hell. Obwohl es sah so aus, als kommt...
Das ist bestimmt gefaked.
Oder Sie schalten die Helligkeit wieder hoch, wenn du rausgehst. Ah nee, es dauert so ein bisschen bis... Also es faded so runter.
Aber du kannst ja... War das nicht so, dass du bei iPhone apps gar nichts machen kannst, beim Verlassen der Anwendung, weil sie die Anwendung richtig crashen? Also du hast ja bei Android...
Nee, du kriegst einen Shutdown. Ja, du kriegst eine Möglichkeit. Das hab ich mir nämlich mal sogar relativ ausführlich angeguckt, wie das jetzt mit iOS 4 ist. Du kriegst mitgeteilt, du wirst jetzt beendet und dann hast du noch irgendwie 10 Sekunden Zeit, dein Ding zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es das schon gibt.
Weil sie haben ja irgendwie, also meinte der Entwickler bei uns in der Firma, dass die Apps einfach crashen, also richtig hart ausmachen und du dann nicht nochmal vorher Bescheid kriegst. Und bei Android kriegst du ja sozusagen diesen Callback, ne?
Nee, du kriegst das mitgeteilt. Du kriegst das auch im Zweifelsfall mitgeteilt, du hast ja noch diese 10 Minuten, wo du noch machen kannst, was du fertig machen musstest. Und auch danach wird dir wohl mitgeteilt, so jetzt hast du ja noch 10 Sekunden. Aber danach wirst du wirklich hart gekillt. Und ja, also dieses Read It Later, ich bin davon hellauf begeistert und so schön ich Instapaper fand und so besser finde ich das. Es macht echt Spaß. Und ich bin mittlerweile so weit, dass ich wirklich Artikel, die ich, wenn ich auf dem Desktop irgendwie einen spannenden Artikel sehe, dass ich nicht nur dann, wenn ich keine Zeit habe, sondern dass ich einfach sage, ok, drücke ich den Read It Later Button oder eben früher den Instapaper Button und damit ich das auf dem iPad lesen kann, weil es da echt viel bequemer ist.
Hier ist übrigens mein Päckchen für meine Reise dieses Wochenende, die mich nach Linz und nach München führen wird. Und für München habe ich mir ja schon ein kleines Paket gemacht. Das sind alles meine kaputten iPhone-Headsets, die ich dann zu diesem Apple Store tragen werde.
Die hast du gesammelt?
Ich habe sie mir übersichtlich hier abgeheftet, damit ich sagen kann, welches, warum tot ist, weil sie alle unterschiedliche Defekte haben. Das eine ist diese Schepper-Problematik. Irgendwie, irgendjemand meinte auch, wenn man so einen Bassboost ausschaltet, dann halten die Dinger länger. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was hier falsch ist. Ich höre ja fast nie Musik. Irgendwie, das ist jetzt glaube ich schon das dritte Apple-Kopfhörer-Teil, wo einfach der Kopfhörer selber durch Schepperei geendet ist. Scheppert dann halt einfach.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Und bei dem anderen iPhone-Headset hatte ich das erste Mal, dass das Mikrofon tot ist.
Also ich hatte das Mikrofon tot, ich hatte das Button nicht mehr funktionieren, also dieser Click-Button, das hatten sie bei den ersten. Da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass der nicht mit nicht-kalifornischen Temperaturen zurechtkommt, dieser Kopfhörer, weil er mir bevorzugt im Winter bei Minustemperaturen ausgefallen ist.
Designed in Kalifornia.
Genau, designed vor Kalifornia.
Nicht vor Kalifornia, eben Kalifornia.
Jaja, aber auch dafür. Ich hatte, dass sich der Gummi ausblößt am Rand von diesem Kopfhörer, dass der so abgeht. Ich glaube, ich hatte schon alle Varianten von iPhone-Kopfhörer tot.
Einfach gehst du in den Store und machst mal reinen Tisch hier.
Dann wird der Apple-Gewinn nächstes Jahr aber anders aussehen.
Ich hab derzeit zwei iPhones, für die noch eine Garantie besteht.
Bei Headset sind die bestimmt entspannt.
Trotzdem gucken sie schon, ob du da eine Garantie hast oder nicht. Dann verkaufen sie dir gerne auch eins.
Na, das stimmt schon.
Ach, die Apple verkauft jetzt auch die Schweine.
Wir wollen unser Geld. Den Eindruck hab ich schon länger. Wollen sie nicht mehr mal ins Rahmen schon. Ich hab mir mal einen näheren Blick geworfen auf diese neuen Kassen, die sie da haben. Ach so, mit diesen... Mit so Windows-Mobile-Devices haben sie ja mal ihre... Ihr Kassensystem. Warst du schon mal in so einem Apple-Store? Früher, damals, als es nur 10 gab.
In Soho noch gerade erst gab's so. In Soho? Also da hatten sie vielleicht drei Apple-Stores so gerade. Da war ich das letzte Mal so richtig in so einem Apple-Store, glaube ich, oder?
Und hatten sie da auch schon die mobilen Kassentermines? Also als sie in England aufgemacht haben, gab's das schon und da hatten sie halt solche Windows-Mobile-Teile. Und dann kam ja irgendwie der iPod Touch und lalala. Und jetzt haben die halt tatsächlich so ein Gerät, wo sie diesen iPod reinstecken. Und ich hab ja auch ein Foto davon, durfte ich machen. Sie war sich nicht ganz so sicher, ob das so okay ist. Und hat mir das so ganz verschämt hingehalten.
Das hat noch so ein Zusatz-Akku drinne, ne?
Dadurch wird das halt, das kann sein, hab ich nicht gesehen. Da ist auch irgendwie ein Laserscanner drin. Und das ist halt dann so ein dickeres Briket. Ich werd das Foto nachher noch posten. Und ja, es ist jetzt eigentlich auch relativ unspektakulär. Ich konnte jetzt nicht im Detail zuschauen. Ich bin noch gar nicht ergoogelt, seh ich jetzt grad selber das erste Mal. L-I-N-E-A-Strich-Pro. Auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie so ein Teil, mit dem sie dann eben so richtig kassig werden. Keine Ahnung, was da alles noch so mit da drin ist.
iPod Touch Portable Barcode Scanner, Max Drive Reader.
Dann ist es im Wesentlichen das. Und genau, richtig, damit du die Kreditkarte dadurch ziehen kannst. Exakt, genau, das war's. Dass man die einfach direkt an so einem mobilen Kassenterminal da irgendwie kaufen kann.
Es gibt doch auch dieses...
Das ist ein Standard-Tool, warum macht ihr da so einen großen Aufwand? Weil die haben ja wahrscheinlich einfach Angst.
Infinite Preferials.
Es gibt doch auch dieses Square-Ding. Diesen Square-Würfel, habt ihr den schon mal gesehen? Der ist ja nicht Square.
Hast du eine 20-seitige Würfel?
Ich weiß, was du meinst, aber hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Der war ja ein großer Spaß. Guter Witz. Das steckt man jetzt auf den Mikrophone-Eingang, auf den Kopfhörerausgang, und dann ist das so ein Kreditkarten-Rittstink.
Das stimmt, und die machen das dann über den Flöteingang?
Die machen das über den Flöteingang, genau. Funktioniert ja irgendwie.
Wie früher, mit einem Akustik-Koppler.
Naja, es ist, glaub ich, gar nicht so doof, weil zum einen brauchen sie nicht diesen Approval mit dem App-Store-Gehickhacke und so was, um sich mit Apple rumprügeln. Zum zweiten geht es auch mit anderen Geräten und nicht nur mit Apple.
Aber das hatten wir auch schon mal in einem Podcast hier übrigens, dass viele Apps, die Dongles supporten, irgendwie Audio-over-Serial machen.
Ich glaube, letztes Mal hatten wir das.
Ich war mal nicht da?
Nein, du warst nicht da? Nein, doch, du warst da.
Dann warst du sogar da, Max.
Dann hab ich einfach nur geschlafen.
Aber du hast recht, du hast ja total recht. Und so ist das. Aber dieses Linear Pro, das scheint so richtig hochoffiziell zu sein. Und macht da so eine richtige Kasse draus. Das ist auf jeden Fall ganz lustig. Und gerade beim iPhone sind. Sieht ja so aus, als ob auch noch diese NFC-Geschichte da mit ins iPhone reinkommt, wenn sie dafür schon einen Engineer haben.
Ach, dieses Near-Field-Communication-Zweckpunkt. Das ist, wir helfen uns mal kurz auf die Sprünge, was das war.
Ja, das ist im Wesentlichen das, was es sagt. Das ist so Near-Field-Communication. Das ist halt so Wireless-Kommunikation über kurzen Räume, so was wie einen Meter oder so. Das hast du irgendwie hier auf jedem Bahnhof.
Ach, das sind diese, wo man dann so seine Fahrkarte davor halten kann, also eine Spezialfahrkarte.
Genau, und um sowas geht's halt auch. Das ist, weiß ich nicht, glaub nicht, dass da passive Elemente mit drin sind.
Okay, wir betreten jetzt den spekulativen Raum.
Nee, doch vielleicht keine gute Idee.
Ja gut, RFID heißt ja, im Wesentlichen ist es ja sozusagen diese Minimal-Version von Funk-Kommunikation, wo du eben die eigentliche Funk-Kommunikation auch noch zum Energieübertragen mit nutzt und dann schwingt das Teil halt so passiv mit. Es gibt natürlich auch aktives RFID, was in dem Sinne dann mehr als nur noch eine ID hat. Hier geht es halt um Near-Field-Communication und da gibt es auch irgendwie eine Batterie von Standards. Irgendwie hier ISO, IEC-Standards, das fällt also im Prinzip da alles mit diesen Short-Range-Kram mit rein. Ich frage mich halt nur, was da kommen wird. In Japan ist das ja extrem populär, gerade für so Ticketing, und es ist durchaus davon auszugehen, dass neue Standards da auf dem Weg sind, wo man dann eben auch noch das iPhone dafür benutzen kann. Warum nicht? Vielleicht hast du dann wirklich dein Bahnticket auf deinem iPhone, und wenn der Schaffner vorbeikommt, dann wedelst du nur noch irgendwie der Asus-Boot und dann geht er weiter.
Also, NFC soll sozusagen to avoid the complicated configuration process, zum Beispiel wie bei Bluetooth. Also, dass er erstmal noch eine PIN eingeben muss.
Genau, mit Pairing und so weiter.
Also, dass man diese komische Apple-ID, mit der man schon Apps kaufen kann und Musik und Filme, dass man mit der auch Kinokarten kaufen kann, das ist jetzt ja nicht so extrem abwegig. Das wär auch da eine spannende Sache, oder?
Die können auch noch PayPal.
Das kann schon kommen, ich weiß bloß halt nicht, was ihre Strategie da ist. Oder ob sie dann eben auch noch gleich... Da gab es auch so eine Business-Unity, die damit zu tun hat. War das nicht sogar Payments Division? Ich hab das jetzt mir nicht so gut notiert. Also man sollte nicht so viel darüber reden, weil ich hab's mir nicht wirklich gut gemerkt. Meine Notizen waren hier sehr eingeschränkt. Aber was ich nicht wusste ist, dass ich mit meinem iPhone auch schon seit mehreren Jahren über ein Flüssig-Metall-Gerät verfügt habe.
Dieses Liquid Metal?
Liquid Metal heißt das, genau. Das ist die Drohne, die Apple jetzt nicht gekauft hat, aber wo sie sich eine Exklusivlizenz zur Anwendung in ihren Produktbereichen gemacht haben. Sie haben denen so viel Geld in den Arsch geschoben, die haben ja danach einen Tag später alle ihre Schulden bezahlt.
Die müssen kurz vor der Pleite gestanden haben.
Nein, Schulden hat man schon mal.
Es waren schon Milliarden von Schulden.
Milliarden waren es nicht, aber es waren so 10 Millionen, glaube ich. Wenn ich mich nicht irre jetzt wieder mit Billionen und Billionen, ich glaube nicht, dass sie 10 Millionen, also so viele Schulden werden sie nicht gehabt haben. Es waren so etwas wie 10 Millionen und die waren dann getilgt. Und das kam gleich nach dieser Veröffentlichung, sodass man vermuten kann, dass was miteinander zu tun hat. Mir war das überhaupt gar nicht bewusst, dass es so etwas gibt.
Also es ist ein Metall, was mit einer extrem hohen Flexibilität oder irgendwie sowas, so wie Plastik. Das kann man gleich. Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Also ich hab gehört, dass es nur...
Egal.
Doch.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Man kann dich gerade nicht verstehen. Also dieses Liquid Metal, das ist da... Die haben da so ein schickes Demovideo, wo sie irgendwie mehrere Stahlkugeln und dieses Liquid Metal Kugel in irgendwie eine Röhre fallen lassen und gucken, wie oft die unten bouncing. Und die Stahlkugel bounce dreimal und Liquid Metal Kugel bounce noch nach 30 Sekunden oder irgendwie sowas ding total schnell. Ja, das war so ein Demovideo, was ich davon gesehen habe. Das Komplizierte daran ist wohl, die Produktion ist gar nicht so teuer, sondern das Problem ist wohl in erster Linie, wie kriegt man es in die Form produziert?
Ja, und das Problem ist, dass die benutzen noch der Platine und Edelmetall, was jetzt auch nicht so gerade preiswert und häufig vorkommt.
Also ich glaube, so teuer war es nicht. Irgendwie war das relativ... Wenn ich das richtig verstand, ist im Wesentlichen der Produktionsprozess noch nicht klar. Also es gab auch nicht das erste... Also Apple wird nicht das erste Gerät rausbringen, was dieses Liquid Metal einsetzt, weil es war schon mal bei einem Samsung-Telefon. Und so für irgendwas gut, aber immer nur für so relativ einfach bearbeitbare Teile, weil so den Produktionsprozess noch niemand drauf hat. Nun gab es dann dieses Gerücht, was ich wirklich für grotesk halte, dass der PIN-SIM-Karten-Ejector, den du gerade in der Hand hältst, vom iPhone und vom iPad, aus diesem Liquid Metal sei. Und ist es nicht? Ich weiß nicht genau, aber wohl erstens nicht in allen Fällen. Also es gibt wohl den Fall, dass das welche aus Stahl ausgeliefert worden sind.
Also es ist nicht an Bendable, aber es ist auf jeden Fall...
Und welche aus Liquid Metal. Und den Gerüchten halbern wohl...
Rechts ist Stahl, links ist Liquid Metal.
So, meine Damen und Herren, hören Sie jetzt und schauen Sie zu, wie dieses Video abläuft. Und dass das wohl nicht bei allen der Fall sein soll und dass die wohl nur in Amerika ausgeliefert worden sind. Diese Liquid Metal-Pin-Dingespunstern.
Das heißt, ich hab hier gar keinen Flüssigmetall in der Hand, sondern das ist alles fake. Das ist einfach normaler Stahl.
Ich würde mal behaupten... also ich weiß es nicht. Und ehrlich gesagt......
mit normalem Spergen Schweiß aus dem Mim. das doch klopft.
Irgendwie erscheint mir das doch ein bisschen konfus, weil die Erklärung dafür war ja, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, dieses Metall in Massenproduktion irgendwie unter die Leute zu bringen oder sowas.
Also ich hab eigentlich gelesen, dass das da liegt, weil die irgendwie Platin oder irgendein Edelmetall reintun und das halt in großen Mengen auch echt teuer oder nicht so in großen Mengen zu beschaffen ist.
Aber warum sollte Apple im großen Stil irgendwie so eine dämlichen Nadel da produzieren? Ich meine, da brauchen sie auch schon ein paar 100 Kilo für, um dann zu gucken, ob aha, wir haben da Nadeln produziert? Ich meine, ich versteh's ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig.
Das werden wir noch sehen.
Ja, das werden wir noch sehen, aber ob das denn wirklich daraus ist... Also ich hab's auf jeden Fall probiert mit den Ejector-Nadeln, die ich so zu Hause rumliegen hatte, was ja nun auch mittlerweile ein paar sind, und die ließen sich alle relativ entspannt verbiegen. Also das war... Das war definitiv nicht dieses harte Material. Und was ich an Beschreibung gelesen habe, wenn es nicht möglich ist, es zu verbiegen, ohne sich dabei zu verletzen, dann hast du Liquid Metal. Und das war bei denen definitiv nicht der Fall, sondern es war relativ easy, da so eine leichte Biegung reinzukriegen.
Okay, zur Kenntnis genommen.
Nummer eins.
Aber komm, ich kann mich mit dem Thema ausmusen, zugeben.
Ja, ich bin beeindruckt.
Ich hab jetzt inzwischen auch mein iPhone 4, weil ich letztes Mal hier noch saß, als einziger iPhone 3GSler zwischen euch ganzen Vierern. Und du meintest ja, dass man es nicht so ganz dringend bräuchte. Ich bin ja da ganz anderer Meinung. Ich find ja, das schickste iPhone, was ich jemals hatte. Mit Abstand.
Jaja, das ist das schickste iPhone.
Dieses Distri ist der Hammer?
Ja, das ist super. Na, brauchen ist ja immer so eine Sache, ne?
Nee, brauchen. Also ich meine, bist du einer von diesen, ich will ja eh nur telefonieren?
Na, ich brauch's.
Ich will FaceTime haben.
Aber man braucht's nicht unbedingt.
Also ich finde dieses Display, dieses Retina-Display, ist es fast schon alleine wert. Der Akku hält wirklich deutlich länger als beim 3GS, zumindest als bei meinem. Also während ich sonst so, naja, eineinhalb Tage, also schaffe ich jetzt locker zwei Tage. Also ich brauch das nicht mehr jede Nacht zu laden wie vorher. Schon dramatischer Unterschied. Die Kamera ist wie gesagt viel besser. Wenn ihr jetzt noch HDR kriegt, dann kreisch ich so ein bisschen beim ersten Foto.
I'm so excited.
Und ich finde halt, ich finde es sieht viel cooler aus und ich finde es fasst sich auch, ich finde so diese Griffigkeit von dem Display, also dieses Gefühl, was man hat, wenn man da so mit dem Finger drüber geht, ist irgendwie viel besser als bei dem 3GS. Und kann das natürlich sein, dass das irgendwie ein Material ist, was ich bei dem 3GS im Laufe der Zeit abgewischt habe, aber irgendwie fasst sich das im Augenblick noch besser an. Hoffentlich bleibt es auch so.
Mir klebt immer dieses Fanboy-Image an.
Ja, ich sag hier noch mal was Positives über Android. Das ist doch der Grund, warum ich nicht dieses Fanboy-Image habe.
Mir fällt bestimmt auch noch was Tolles ein.
Aber ich kriege das, also mit dieser Antenne, ich bin ja nun Linkshänder und ich halte es wahrscheinlich auch so in der Hand, wie man es nicht halten sollte. Ich hab es tatsächlich geschafft, also ich muss manchmal, während bei Telefonaten kriege ich mit, dass die Verbindung gleich zusammenbricht, also dass die wirklich die Sprachqualität extrem schlecht wird und dass wenn ich es dann ein bisschen anders halte, nämlich dass ich es dann nicht mehr so halte, also mit abgedeckt die Antenne, sondern so halte, dass es dann quasi augenblicklich, also innerhalb von ein paar Sekunden deutlich besser wird. Und das ist nicht eingebildet, sondern wirklich die Sprachqualität so ist, dass man so, manchmal hat man ja, wenn dieser GSM-Algorithmus, dass es dann so scheppern klingt, so metallisch, so als ob man mit einem Roboter sprechen würde. Und das kriege ich hin, wenn ich hier die Hand entsprechend halte, versehentlich.
Ich habe hier noch kurz diesen Einwurf gefunden. Ja, das Liquid Metal Material ist irgendwie ziemlich prohibitively expensive, weil es irgendwie large amounts of platinum enthält und das kostet 1500 Dollar per ounce. Also wir dürfen gespannt sein, wo sie das einbauen.
In Steve Jobs neuem Haus.
Vielleicht brauchen sie das ja einfach nur, um kleine Brücken und Verbinder zu bauen, die einfach hochstabil sein müssen, wodurch sie sich dann andere Sachen sparen können. Mal sehen.
Vielleicht ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Also ich habe ja jetzt diesen Bumper.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du den auch schon einbestellt hast. Den habe ich deshalb drauf.
Hast du den jetzt schon bei Apple bestellt?
Ich habe diesen Apple Bumper. Abgesehen davon, dass ich den recht schick finde, hat er den Vorteil, dass er einen anderen Nachteil des iPhone 4 ausgleicht. Nämlich, dass man nicht mehr so leicht weiß, wo vorne und hinten ist. Wenn man sich das aus der Tasche rauszieht, ist es auch so glatt, dass es so schwer rauszuziehen ist. Vorher war das irgendwie einfacher.
Damit habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme, weil ich schon immer das iPhone so in die Tasche gesteckt habe, dass die Glasseite, also die Displayseite, zum Körper ist, damit, falls ich mit dem Fahrrad hinfalle, ich nicht direkt als allererstes das Display kaputt mache. Und darum habe ich das sowieso. Darum weiß ich einfach, wie ich es in der Tasche habe. Mir ist nur aufgefallen, dass ich über diese Problematik auch nachgedacht habe.
Ja gut, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, so ist das. Und vielleicht, weil ich diesen Bumper habe, habe ich jetzt auch keinerlei. Aber ich hatte auch schon vorher irgendwie keine Probleme. Aber ich telefoniere auch nicht so viel, muss ich dazu sagen. Und wenn, dann telefoniere ich gerne mit meinem Headset. Dann habe ich das Ding sowieso nicht in Ahnung.
Mit Headset telefoniere ich auch gerne.
Nur, dass mein Headset jetzt gerade kaputt ist.
Und hinten hat es keine Protektion. Ich habe diesen...
Nein, das ist nur so einmal drumherum.
Ich habe diesen Incase-Bumper, der so transparent ist.
Also ich finde den von Apple, ich finde...
Der erhält einfach die Hübschheit von diesem Telefon.
Naja, das finde ich jetzt übertrieben.
Man sieht jetzt nicht auf Anhieb, dass du ein iPhone 4 auf jeden Fall hast.
Nein, man sieht nicht auf Anhieb, dass es eigentlich ein iPhone 5 Prototyp ist, den mir Steve selber in die Hand gegeben hat.
Das kann man übrigens gar nicht mehr halten beim Telefonieren.
Ich darf bloß jetzt nicht mehr in die Bars gehen.
Ja, aber ich finde... Doch, ich finde alle diese Bumper-Cases ausgesprochen hässlich gerade an diesem wirklich sehr schönen Telefon. Aber es geht noch so halbwegs. Ich finde die Tasten sind relativ gut gelöst, aber ich hatte mal für mein iPhone 3G einen Bumper-Case, da war es einfach nur so Gummi, was außen drum ist, und bei dem hier sind ja doch die Tasten so ein bisschen vorhanden. Das haben sie schon ganz hübsch gemacht. Er hat das, er hat das. Warte mal, ich hab den dabei sogar.
Und du hast auch einen Apple-Bumper?
Nein, man kann sich den ja aussuchen, und ich hab dann einfach den Apple-Bumper genommen. Ich hab jetzt einen gesehen, auf irgendeiner Website, der kostet auch ein Schweinegeld. Die muss man mit so einer kleinen Schraube zumachen. Der sah extrem schick aus. Ja, der war so mit so kleiner Schraube. Ne, mit so kleinen Schräuben. Razor, oder ich weiß nicht, wie das Ding heißt. Da musste man so ein kleines Schräubchen festdrehen. Und hier ist mein Papa. Und der sah dann so ein bisschen...
Achso, die haben hier die Knöpfe nochmal extra rausgedrückt.
Genau, die sind nochmal so als Tasten quasi nachgebildet. Also ich meine, 20 Dollar dafür zu nehmen, ist natürlich trotzdem komplett überteuert, aber für Apple-Verhältnisse ist es geradezu günstig.
Ja, also ich hab ja auch gedacht, irgendwie bestellt ihr halt diesen komischen Bumper, wenn er gratis ist, ne? Und so bisher hat er mich noch nicht genervt, dass ich ihn auch tatsächlich immer noch draufgelassen habe. Ich hab diesen voll transparenten von Incase, mir ist es auch letztens mal runtergefallen, genau auf den Bumper. Ist auch nichts passiert?
Voll auf den Bumper.
Voll mal auf den Bumper, Baby.
Also kann man schonmal machen mit diesen Bumpern, dafür sind sie ja auch da.
Dass man sie auch mal runterschmeißt.
Genau, also wenn ich meinen Bumper habe, schmeiß ich mein Telefon täglich runter.
Jetzt kann man es endlich mal wieder an die Wand feuern, wenn so ein Vollidiot anruft. Papa-Cases.
Es ist ja eine Diskussion, die uns nicht wirklich verfolgt, aber ich habe so ein bisschen darüber gegrübelt, ob meine ursprüngliche Einschätzung, dass das auf keinen Fall kommt, nämlich dieses CDMA-iPhone in den USA.
Was ist denn CDMA? Ein anderes Netzwerk oder was?
Das ist so dieses alternative GSM für Arme.
Naja, es ist ein anderer Mobilfunkstandard, der eigentlich so nur noch in den USA und so eigentlich auch nur noch von einem einzigen Netzwerk benutzt wird, was aber mal so eben so das...
Sind das nicht sogar zwei? Verizon, CDMA und Sprint nicht auch?
Sprint...
Das war so bestimmt die Wikipedia.
Ist auch, aber die haben einen anderen Pfad.
Wie war denn das?
Ich such mal mit Google Voice Search. Die sind schon müde beim Tippen hier.
Sprint, next tier ist es.
Ja.
Ja, Sprint, wie auch immer. Das ist halt zwei. Wobei Sprint halt... Oh man, ich werd zu müde, ich krieg's gar nicht... Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist es nicht GSM. Und würde man jetzt ein iPhone bauen, was diese CDMA-Technologie drin hat, dann würde es halt nur in den USA funktionieren.
Genau.
Ich war bisher in meiner Meinung, dass es nicht kommt. Ich bin in meiner Meinung, Apple baut sowas nicht. Die bauen einfach nur eins.
Und was hat dich jetzt in deiner Meinung geändert, diese Job-Ausschreibung?
Das hat mich gar nichts in meiner Meinung geändert, nur dass halt so eine Gerichtedichte am Start ist, die halt der Meinung ist, das wäre jetzt total sicher, das kommt dann irgendwie im Januar und so weiter. Aber I'm not sold on this.
Naja, was mich dann auch so ein bisschen überzeugt hat, oder nicht überzeugt hat, aber mich hat stutzig werden lassen, also ich sehe das genauso wie du, da ist eine hohe Gerüchtedichte, aber die gibt es jetzt auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Also dass jetzt Apple nicht mehr bei AT&T ist, gerade in Amerika, die scheinen da echt unter AT&T so richtig schlimm zu leiden und so was. Da gibt es ja schon lange Gerüchte, dass das mal geändert wird und dass es jetzt im Januar das CDMA-iPhone kommen soll, das hört man jetzt auch schon ein bisschen länger. Jetzt hat aber ja irgendwie Qualcomm, Qualcomm, Qualcomm, wie spricht Qualcomm?
Qualcomm.
Qualcomm. Die haben ja eine Jobausschreibung gehabt, dass sie einen iPhone-Entwickler suchen, der so sagt, du glaubst, dass du alles wüsstest über das iPhone, wir zeigen dir was, was du noch nicht weißt, nach dem Motto.
Ein iPhone-Entwickler im Sinne von iPhone-Software-Entwickler.
Ich weiß, was...
Ein iPhone-Hardware-Entwickler gibt es wahrscheinlich so auf dem Markt nicht. Das ist zumindest noch kein Ausbildungsberuf, soweit ich weiß.
Ein iPhone-Hardware-Entwickler? Klar, wir dreien uns.
Wie viele iPhones haben sie denn schon so entwickelt?
Was meinst du, wie sollen die sonst die ganzen Prototypen verlieren?
Ja, das ist halt genau dieses Problem mit dieser ganzen Gerüchtelage. Da hört man immer gleich irgendwas, aber die Frage ist, also der einzige Grund, den ich sehe, den Apple haben könnte so was zu tun, ist, dass sie in irgendeiner Form beunruhigt sind, weil Android in diesem Verizon-Markt halt Bodengut macht, während sie eigentlich in allen anderen Märkten, wo es ein iPhone gibt, eben durchaus noch die Nase vorn haben. Das ist eigentlich das Einzige, was dafür spricht.
Vielleicht denken Sie auch, wir haben einen Provider tot gekriegt, da kriegen wir auch noch einen zweiten tot.
Wie was tot gekriegt?
Na ja, im Sinne von die Daten-Rate ist so hoch, dass wir jetzt...
Na ja, die Frage ist halt, lohnt sich das? Also was wäre der Grund für Apple, das zu tun?
Steve Jobs hat sich sogar schon mal geäußert zu dem Thema, jetzt nicht im Sinne von so oder so, aber er hat gesagt, man muss immer abwägen. Es gibt Entwicklungskosten auf der einen Seite und es gibt halt so und so großes der Markt. Dann werden sie sich das sicherlich relativ gut ausrechnen. Und wenn es da gutes Geld zu verdienen gibt, und nicht nur ein bisschen Geld, dann wird Apple das... Also ich meine, die wären doof, wenn sie das nicht machen würden.
Ja gut, aber sie würden halt Telefone bauen, die irgendwie nicht international rum können.
Ja, aber das waren sie doch auch für China zum Beispiel.
In China machen sie auch UMTS.
Ja, UMTS, aber war das nicht so, dass sie in China den WLAN-Chip weglassen müssen?
Nein, sie haben den WLAN-Chip drin gehabt.
Aber abgeschaltet?
Sie haben ihn dann abgeschaltet am Anfang. Mittlerweile haben sie ja ein Software-Update geliefert, womit sie dieses spezielle chinesische Login-Protokoll machen, was halt da rekomendiert ist. Du darfst ja nicht einfach so WLAN benutzen, sondern du musst dich da halt genauso beim Chef einbuchen, wie du das halt über GSM auch machst. Und ich weiß mal ganz genau, wie es heißt, aber das ist sozusagen mandatory in China.
Aber das ist eine reine Software-Sache.
Soweit ich weiß, ist das eine reine Software-Sache.
Okay, also keine eigene Hardware-Sache.
Es ist so ein Level, es kann sein, dass es so ein Level-2-Protokoll-Ding ist.
Okay.
Dann ist es nicht over IP, sondern sozusagen bevor da die Kommunikation ist, hast du so eine Authentication, bevor dann sozusagen der eigentliche WLAN-Kram dann zum Laufen kommt und du darüber IP kriegst. Aber da bin ich, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt, ein bisschen zu wenig darüber, aber das ist halt dieses speziell chinesische Ding, was sie da implementiert haben.
Sie liefern keine spezielle...
Das ist die selbe Hardware.
Gut, dann nehme ich halt zurück und behaupte das Gegenteil.
Genau. Und das war auch, ja, kannst du auch mal ein paar Sendungen zurückspulen. Ich hab immer gesagt, wenn sie nach China gehen, dann gehen sie mit China Unicom, weil die einfach ein OMTS-Netz haben. So ist es gekommen.
Ja, okay, also dass sie da keinen, dass sie da erstmal den Sonderweg nicht machen.
Genau. Und China Telecom hat ja einen anderen Netzstandard und den haben sie halt nicht gemacht. Und irgendwie so auf einem weltweiten Scale spielt dann eben Reisen auch nicht mehr so die große Rolle.
Ja, aber die müssen auch irgendwann den amerikanischen Markt. Der ist halt wichtig. Da sind sie zu Hause und...
Ja gut, aber dieser amerikanische Markt entwickelt sich halt auch in Richtung...
Na eher in Richtung...
4G. 4G, OMTS 4G.
Also das ist, glaube ich, das beste Argument, warum jetzt noch auf CDMA gehen, wenn in drei Jahren 4G aktuell ist.
Sie machen halt LTE, über kurz oder lang, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie jetzt schon irgendwie an ihrem LTE-Phone arbeiten und irgendwann...
Das stimmt wesentlich eher, als dass jetzt ein CDMA einfach...
Bloß es wird natürlich auch noch sehr lange dauern, bis in den USA flächendeckend LTE da ist.
Die haben wir noch nicht mal flächendeckend, GSM. So richtig.
Ich kann in der Zwischenzeit berichten, dass dieses Epic-Citadel... Das sieht ganz schön, also für so ein Frauenspiel, boah, muss ich sagen. Also hier passiert halt nichts. Das ist wahrscheinlich die Demo, dass du eben mal rumlaufen kannst in dem Level, um zu gucken, wie schick es aussieht. Aber das sieht richtig gut aus.
Das ist wirklich beeindruckende Kram, das stimmt. Habt ihr von dieser AR-Drohne gehört?
Und dass ihr eine verloren habt auf der Volksbühne.
Ich hab die nicht verloren, aber mein Freund hat die verloren, die sich das Teil gekauft hat. Das war etwas dramatisch. Er hat sich das Teil gekauft bei Saturn, eins von diesen 15, die da rausgegeben wurden. Dann kam er irgendwie hierher, dann haben wir ein paar Tissflüge gemacht, dann sind wir abends nach Hause gefahren, hat das Ding vor der Volksbühne gestartet und dann ist es ihm in den Himmel entschwunden. Das Problem war vermutlich, das ist nämlich ein bisschen plastemäßig. Also wovon wir überhaupt reden? Also AR-Drone ist so ein Quadrocopter, der fernsteuerbar ist über W-Lanen und der gleich mit einer iPhone-iPad-Applikation kommt. Also eine iPhone-Applikation, die auf dem iPad ein Doppelsogroß genauso funktioniert. Die hat zwei Kameras, eine, die nach vorne zeigt, eine, die nach unten zeigt, hat Ultraschallsensoren für Höhenerkennung und kann sich beliebig drehen. Du kannst es in Echtzeit steuern und siehst das Kamerabild dann auch auf deinem iPhone. Das heißt, das Ding streamt dann auch noch. Es hält irgendwie 12 Minuten mit einer Akkuladung, die dann eineinhalb Stunden aufladen musst. Und das Ding ist halt extrem billig. Das kostet irgendwie 300 Euro. Und da ist halt die ganze Hardware-Software mit dabei. Das ist schon sehr wenig Geld.
Das iPhone auch.
Man merkt das...
Aber ein iPod Nano.
Man merkt das diesem Copter auch an. Im Vergleich zu diesem besseren Quadrocopter, wie man ihn so auf dem Kongress und so weiter immer sieht, ist das sehr viel plastiger als... Ist das ein Wort? Nein. Plastik-mäßiger, wie auch immer. Uns ist das Teil dann beim Testen auch in so ein Gebüsch reingeflogen, wie das eben so passiert. Und dann hat es irgendwie so einen leichten Schlag bekommen. Also es war dann irgendwie nass und dreckig. Und dann war es so ein bisschen... Oder es ging die Erde gekommen, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall waren diese Zahnräder, die da relativ offen sind, sind so Zahnräder, die dann halt diese Rotoren antreiben. Das ist irgendwie alles keine besonders robuste Konstruktion. Das ist wirklich eine sehr billige Konstruktion, das merkt man. Und das war dann irgendwie dreckig und dann haben die sich nicht so schnell gedreht und dadurch hatte das Ding so einen Schlag. Das heißt, normal hast du in der Luft stehen lassen, nach diesem kleinen Crash driftete es halt so ein bisschen weg. Und irgendwie ist eben das Ding irgendwie nach oben gestiegen, man wollte dann vielleicht das WLAN abgerissen, hat den Kommando nach unten nicht mehr mitbekommen, ist dann irgendwie aufgestiegen und dabei weggedriftet und dann war es halt irgendwie weg. Ein Drama.
Also ich hab gesehen...
So eine Telefonnummer in die A-R-Drohne erst mal ran kleben.
Ja, würde ich auf jeden Fall erst mal raten. Also es ist Spielzeug. Es ist wirklich Spielzeug.
Aber für 300 Euro gerade gekauft und dann...
Ja, es ist dramatisch.
Ich arbeite in dem Gebäude, wo die Pressekonferenz war, wo sie das Ding vorgestellt haben, da im E-Werk. Da bin ich dann abends aus dem Büro gekommen und da haben die das gerade präsentiert. Dann hab ich davon ein iPhone-Video gemacht und hab das dann auf Twitter gestellt. Und lustigerweise genau das Bild, also ich hab neben dem Kamera...
Auf Twitter gestellt?
Ja, so mit Twittpick oder ich weiß nicht, irgendwie. Ist schon eine Weile her. Und lustigerweise ein paar Tage später, ich glaube auf golem.de oder so, war nicht mein Video, sondern ein Kameramann, der daneben stand, für den sie gerade die Demo gemacht haben, die ich einfach mitgefilmt habe. Wo sie das gerade gemacht haben, das war schon ganz... Also er hat sich oder das sah so aus, als ob es nicht so deutlich gut klappen würde, weil derjenige, der das gesteuert hat, konnte das überhaupt nicht. Aber dann hab ich noch mal eins gesehen vor der Bundesdruckerei, erstaunlicherweise, wo da einer mit rumgespielt hat. Und das sah schon ziemlich talentiert aus. Der hat sich echt Mühe gegeben, er ist relativ flach geflogen und sowas. Wahrscheinlich hat ihm genau sowas nicht passiert. Vielleicht war das ja dein Kumpel und das war schon die zweite. Und wundert mich da ein bisschen, dass da nicht Security nicht eingeschritten ist. Vor der Bundesdruckerei mit so einer kleinen Drohne rumfliegen, das stell ich mir schon ganz lustig vor. Wie ist denn das? Das hat eine Kamera an Bord?
Zwei.
Da vorne einer unten und streamt live.
Ach, streamt live. Und kann man auch aufzeichnen?
Nein, ist nicht live. Das kommt alles eine halbe Stunde verspült. Das speichert erst mal zwischen auf den zwei 500 Gigabyte Platten an Bord.
Ich meine, es gibt doch diese... Ist das denn HTTPS-Streaming? Die Apple TV.
Das heißt, du kannst die Drohnen direkt auf die Apple TV streamen lassen, auf dem Fernseher.
Ist das dann auf die AM geschützt?
Bestimmt.
Und geht das auch in die andere Richtung?
Du kannst auch J-Breaken und einen Windows-Media-Center drauf installieren.
Die Sendung ist schon vorbei.
Ich glaube, Huckel hat keinen Bock mehr.
Das sind schon alle ganz schön...
Ich bin schon ein bisschen durch, aber ich habe noch ein paar Themen hier am Start. Was denn los? Wir haben noch keine drei Stunden hier eingefahren.
Also ich kann auch noch. Wir sind sehr stammt.
So ein Whisky oder ein Rum oder ein Wolke.
Okay, Leute, wir haben viele Themen, die wir in die nächste Sendung tragen werden, aber ich möchte noch zwei, drei Sachen anbringen. Und zwar wollte ich vor allem erstmal noch zwei Tools vorstellen, die bei mir gerade hier im Einsatz sind. Das Erste hat bei mir nämlich ein echtes Problem gelöst, was ich schon seit langem habe. Ihr kennt das. Wenn man sich so Filme aus dem Internet leiht.
Meinst du leihen oder leihen?
Na, so über den Leihprotokoll herunter lädt. Und da die ja dann in der Regel von so... Wie soll ich es formulieren? Also, diese Filme sind dann in MKV-Format.
Ja.
Ich stell mich mal kurz hin. Das sind Matroska-Format, MKV. Ich weiß nicht, wie eure Erfahrungen damit so sind.
Habe ich ganz gut.
Aber meine sind eher, na ja.
Das ist nicht MPEG-4.
Es ist MPEG-4 in den meisten Fällen. Das handelt sich nur um einen anderen Container. Mit dem Problem, dass du dann halt so spezielle Programme brauchst, um das irgendwie abzuspielen. Du kriegst dann halt dieses File nicht auf deinem iPhone zum Laufen und nicht auf deinem iPad zum Laufen, sondern du bist halt gezwungen, das auf so ein Computer, wo externer Software läuft, also VLC oder sonst irgendwas abzuspielen.
M-Player Extended kann ich dir empfehlen.
Oder M-Player Extended, wie auch immer. Halt diese Programme mit diesen komischen Versionsnummern. Wie auch immer. Ich hab es nicht so richtig eingesehen. Da kommt dann dieser Film und alles ist MPEG 4, nur das Container-Format nicht. Was einfach erstmal Probleme erzeugt. Ich wollte dann halt einfach die Serien auf meinem iPhone gucken. Dann hab ich die dann alle reencoded und hab das immer nicht eingesehen, warum ich etwas reencode, was eigentlich schon richtig codiert ist, weil das ist ja nur der Container, der falsch ist.
Und jetzt hast du was, was den Container auswechselt. Genau.
Es gibt ein Programm auf dem Mac, das heißt MKV Tools. Und das tut genau das. Du nimmst ein MKV Movie und du kannst in normal MPEG 4 und auch verschiedene andere Formate, auch in AVI übrigens, umrechnen. Und kannst aber dabei eben für das Video Pass Ruh machen. Das heißt, du klickst einfach an Video Pass Ruh und dann geht das auch ratze fatze. Das heißt, du kannst da irgendeinen 1080p MKV Movie nehmen. Sagst hier MKV Tools, lad mal, pack das Ganze mal in einem P4-Container, behalte einfach alles bei und Video macht Pass Ruh. Und dann bei dem Audio kannst du ja dann irgendwie das noch auf Stereo runterrechnen, wenn du möchtest, falls 5.1 nicht geht. Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht so sicher, ob 5.1 Support so im iPhone drin ist, ob der mit so einem AC3-Tonspur klar kommt, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall kannst du das halt dann auch umrechnen, sodass du das hast. Audio umrechnen ist ja nicht so das Problem. Video ist das Problem. Und mit MKV Tools geht das wunderbar. Und ist kostenlos, wenn du so ein Next Screen kurz vor dem Prozess sozusagen erträgst. Du kannst das dann irgendwie kaufen. Hätte ich auch gekauft, aber es war dann wieder so eine Bedingung, die ich hasse. Nämlich so mit, du musst für jeden deiner Computer eine eigene Lizenz kaufen. Und ich enforce das auch noch. Und das ist dann immer so der Punkt, wo ich sage, nee, Jungs, so funktioniert das nicht. Mit Software kaufen, wie auch immer. Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Eigentlich, wo du gerade Pass-Through erwähnst, das nicht der VLC auch. Der kann ja auch Transcoden und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt so, wo du gerade Pass-Through gesagt hast.
Ja, theoretisch gibt es diese Option. Und mir wird das auch immer wieder gesagt.
Aber wie man es macht, hab ich auch noch nicht rausgefilmt.
Aber es ist mir noch nie gelungen.
Also da gibt es irgendwie mir zu viele Commando-Zeiten. Ich hab das ein paar Mal probiert und das Ergebnis war immer so 0-Bite-Files oder so. Wahrscheinlich nur zu doof und so weiter. Ihr wisst es ja alle. Tatsache ist, mit diesem Tool ging es.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Und das auch für doof.
Was ich jetzt noch mal ausprobiert habe, ist R-Video. Was ja bestimmt auch alle kennen fürs iPhone und fürs iPad. Packt das irgendwo auf deinen Mac oder PC oder was auch immer, so ein kleiner Server und der macht dann Re-Encoding. Re-Encoding. On-Demand. Ach, egal. Der rechnet das in Echtzeit um. Und das funktioniert auch, wenn man einen halbwegs schnellen Rechner hat. Das funktioniert hervorragend übers Netz.
Aber funktioniert das auch noch, wenn du einen 24 GB Blu-ray-Abzug auf der Platte hast?
Bestimmt. Denk vom Prozessor ab. Also mit dem Prozessor klappt das bestimmt. Also mit so einem iMac.
Ja, aber du brauchst halt immer noch so ein 8-Core-Computer im Hintergrund, um da auf deinem iPhone dir was anzugucken.
Ja, aber so ein 8-Core-Computer, den hab ich sowieso rumstehen und ja.
Du kannst das halt nur zu Hause machen.
Nee, der steht bei Hetzner.
Da kannst du es nur machen, wenn du Internet hast.
Das stimmt.
Nee, man kann auch mit R-Video vorher runterladen.
Achso, das geht sozusagen auch auf Linux und so?
Offiziell geht es nur auf Mac und unter Windows. Die entwickeln offensichtlich auch in Java so einen Linux-Server. Wenn man mal R-Video-Linux-Server bei Google eingibt, dann findet man so eine fantastische Anleitung für Ubuntu, in der man nicht viele Ubuntu-Anleitungen erlebt, an der jeder Schritt einfach stimmt. Und wo ich die Erfahrung gemacht habe, dass alles, was man da so eintippt, genauso funktioniert hat bei mir. Damit hatte ich 1.Pix.3, so einen schönen kleinen Server, am Laufen.
Verstehe. Dann hast du da einfach so deinen Fileshare im Netz und da wirst du dann irgendwie...
Mit HTTP-Streaming!
Dann kannst du dann so beliebige...
HTTP-Streaming hätte ich natürlich noch viel lieber, aber...
Dann kannst du ganz so beliebigen Encoding-Dreck da draufschmeißen.
Man schmeißt da rein, was man will und es geht. Also ich hab das... Friss. Also bisher, also ich hab das jetzt so seit Dienstag oder so. Nee, ein bisschen länger heißt es schon, aber jetzt so seit ein paar Tagen und hab mir da für darüber so 2, 3 Serien angeguckt und hat alles ganz gut funktioniert.
Und das Leben ist besser.
Das Leben ist besser. Das Leben in der Wolke ist besser.
Und jetzt nochmal noch, ich weiß, wir haben das bestimmt auch schon mal hier erwähnt, aber so als dritten Videotipp für doch mal Video am Rechner gucken. Ja, also wenn man so einen zum Beispiel 24 Gigabyte Blu-Ray-Abzug irgendwie zufällig rumlegen hat und den abspielen will und irgendwie ruckelt's, weil irgendwie der Rechner das nur auf einem Core decodet und so weiter. Und es auch noch ein MKV ist, was jetzt das QuickTime nicht direkt abspielen kann. Also dieser M-Player Extended, der ist echt ganz cool geworden. Mittlerweile ist halt so eine GUI-Variante vom M-Player für OS X so entklickbar. Und er hat halt eine tolle Option. Du kannst halt FFmpeg MT einschalten und dann decoded der Multithreaded und macht halt so viel wie er braucht, um halt dein Video flüssig zu kriegen. Und ich hatte halt echt schon ein paar HD-Videos, die haben geruckelt in allen Tools und mit FFmpeg MT, also in diesem M-Player drinnen gleich zum Klicken, kein Problem. So der geht dann so auch ohne Gnade einfach auf 190% CPU, wenn es mal sein muss, wenn die Bitrate zu hoch ist, wie auch immer. Und damit kann man echt so auch mal die dicken Pfeils problemfrei gucken. Und das ist halt eigentlich so, dass M-Player, die benutzen ja FFmpeg zum Videodekoden. Und dann haben halt Leute gesagt, hey, wir könnten das ja mal multithreaded machen. Und dann hatten aber die M-Player Jungs oder die FFmpeg Jungs nicht so richtig Lust drauf. Dann haben die es halt geforkt. Und jetzt gibt es so, das schon so zum Klicken im den M-Player Extended Preferences kannste sagen, ich hätte aber lieber gerne FFmpeg MT und dann. Ist schon eingestellt, Default?
War bei mir eingestellt, ich weiß nicht, ob du es schon mal gemacht hast vielleicht.
Wie gesagt, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass wir das schon mal erwähnt hatten, weil man guckt ja eh nur noch HD-Filme und...
Ich hab das aber noch nicht benutzt. Ich hab's nur installiert gehabt, warum auch immer.
Also wie gesagt, ich muss sagen, für so die Härtefette war das bisher dann immer noch der, der am ehesten...
Gut.
Gut, hätten wir die Videotools auch abgearbeitet.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, H264. Ihr habt sicherlich davon gelesen. Keine Lizenz auf dem Internet.
Nee, aber...
Naja, mit diesem Keine Lizenz... Also so würd ich's ja nicht vornehmen.
Ja, das war...
Also so ist es ja nicht, sondern... Also was war das Problem? Das Problem war oder ist eigentlich auch immer noch, dass die Welt kennt Patente. Und darauf gibt's eine ganze Menge, die diesen Videocodec-Kram betreffen. Und es gibt verschiedene Leute, die der Meinung sind, sie hätten patentfreie Codecs. Und es gibt viele Leute, die der Meinung sind, dass die Leute, die das behaupten, das zu Unrecht behaupten. Und dieser Streit ist so noch nicht entschieden. Vor allem gibt's halt diesen Kampf zwischen dem Ok-Lager und mittlerweile auch dem Google-Lager namens WebM versus dem Weltstandard H264. Und... Naja, jetzt gab's diese Ankündigung von der MPEG LA, also der Licensing Agency, die diese Patent-Pools bereitstellt, wo man sich sozusagen eine Lizenz klicken kann und dann hat man eben den kompletten Pool, so wie man ihn braucht, ohne dass man sich mit den einzelnen Patentinhabern einzeln abstimmen müssen. So, und die hat halt immer gesagt, naja, ab 2011 oder 2013, was war's jetzt, würden sie halt... Bitte?
2013.
Ja, ursprünglich war's glaube ich 2011, dann haben sie es jetzt vor kurzem nochmal verschoben und die Aussage war halt, auch wenn du eben kostenlos das verwendest, ab einer bestimmten Zahl von Downloads und so weiter bestimmte obskure Bedingungen, musst du halt Geld zahlen. Das heißt, freie Angebote so sind nicht so ohne weiteres möglich. Und das hat im Wesentlichen dazu beigetragen, denke ich mal, dass es auch zu dieser Web-M-Geschichte kam. Und ich habe, glaube ich nicht hier, war hier immer das gar nicht so besprochen, aber ich erinnere mich noch, ich war beim Medienradio, da war das irgendwie ganz ausufernd ein Thema.
Wir haben auch lange darüber diskutiert, über die verschiedenen Panzer, die so rausgeholt werden.
Haben wir auch über diese Web-M-Geschichte, hatten wir auch. Okay, ja, wie auch immer. Ich hatte ja immer schon diese Vermutung geäußert, ob es nicht vielleicht nur so eine Keule ist, die Google da rausholt, um mehr Druck auszuüben. Wenn es so war, dann hat der Druck offensichtlich ein bisschen was gebracht. Auf jeden Fall haben die sich jetzt wohl erpressen lassen und haben gesagt, dass was frei ist im Netz. Und jetzt ist halt da von Internet downloads die Rede, glaube ich, in diesem Dokument und alle Medienvertreter haben es als Streaming bezeichnet, was natürlich irgendwie Quatsch ist. Das ist eben Freibliebe.
Für alle Ewigkeiten.
Genau, das heißt aber, dass wenn du eben kostenpflichtige Sachen hast, also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Videopodcaster bin, der seinen Content verkauft, dann gilt das ja nicht. Sondern dann musst du halt unter Umständen doch eine Lizenz zahlen für die Verwendung dieses Formates.
Das ist der Grund, warum die meisten Videokameras, die man so kaufen kann, heutzutage eine Ausnahme irgendwo in den Handbüchern drin stehen haben, dass man damit keinen professionellen Content erstellen darf.
Ich könnte sagen, dass die Ausnahme jetzt ein bisschen anders ist. Also so richtig geklärt ist die ganze Geschichte noch nicht. Weil was ist kostenlos? Entfällt die Kostenlosigkeit in dem Moment, wo ich Werbung da drüber schalte. Entfällt es, wenn ich irgendwie Affiliate-Links auf meiner Webseite habe.
Was sagt Fletter dazu?
Was sagt Fletter dazu? Und vor allem, wie wirkt sich das auf kommende Zustände, zukünftige Standards aus? Weil sie sind ja schon am 2H265 am Arbeiten. Das kommt jetzt nicht unbedingt morgen, aber da wollen sie wahrscheinlich auch relativ fix hin. Unklar.
Du, H264?
Na, aber diesen Schritt...
Na ja, das ist natürlich in die richtige Richtung, aber ein komplett offenes Format wäre doch immer noch die schönere Sache. Und hoffentlich kriegen wir es irgendwann mal.
Der Buyout. Wir brauchen den Buyout.
Der Buyout ist gar nicht so schlecht überspricht. MPEG LA, bringen wir so einen Fletter-Button an. Und wenn da genug zusammengekommen ist, dann stellst du den Quellcode rein und dann sagst du, es ist jut.
Andererseits, lass das doch jetzt Google einfach. Also ich meine, die haben doch gesagt, wir haben schon Patentsüt irgendwie am Start und wir klagen Google die Hucke voll. Ja, und lass sie doch jetzt erstmal da ihr Geld verbrennen, irgendwie alle gegenseitig und gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Dann wird es ja noch teurer.
Oder einfach die Konkursmasse aufkommen.
Vielleicht haben sie das auch gemacht, weil sie gemerkt haben, wir haben zwar hier so Patente, aber ob wir denen jetzt so richtig beikommen können? Die Sache ist ja mit diesen Patenten, die haben ja alle viele Patente. Wenn jetzt die einen ankommen und sich raustrauen, wir verklagen euch und sagen, wir haben auch Patente. Lass mal sehen, was ihr so habt.
Also ich glaube ja nach wie vor, dass das mit diesem Web-Im eigentlich nirgendswo hinführt, weil über kurz oder lang werden die sich eh auf die ganzen Sachen einfallen, einlassen müssen, die jetzt in diesem ganzen H-Punkt-Stern-Prozess abgehen. Ich habe ein bisschen in H265 reingelesen, da geht es halt jetzt, also diese neue Codex-Sammlung soll schon auf H264 aufbauen, ist aber jetzt nicht unbedingt als Erweiterung geplant, sondern wollen so einen eigenen Standard-Set draus machen. Lebt aber quasi viele dieser Dinge einfach weiter, aber sie wollen halt auf höhere Effizienz, also nennen den auch High-Efficiency-Video-Codec, also derzeit ist es ja der Advanced-Video-Codec, und H265 ist dann der High-Efficiency, das heißt, sie wollen bei gleicher Prozessorbelastung mit der halben Bandbreite auskommen, oder mit mehr CPU kommen sie dann sozusagen auch auf bessere Ergebnisse und so weiter. Also das ist sehr ambitioniert, was da drin steht. Aber letzten Endes heißt das, da ist ein Standard in Sicht innerhalb dieses selben Tracks, der eben noch weniger Bandbreite verbraucht, oder noch bessere Bilder erzeugt bei gleicher Bandbreite. Was natürlich alle haben wollen.
Was halt bei den MPEG-Leuten eben auch noch der Fall ist, dass da halt viele große Player Geld drauf werfen in die Entwicklung, und da muss man erstmal sehen, wie jetzt andere, also wenn jetzt Google sagt, okay wir wollen jetzt ein Open-Codec haben, ob die dann halt auch so das so pushen und da so viel Entwickler-Hirn-Schmalz draufschmeißen, dass sie da immer mithalten können mit den Entwicklungen. Also wenn jetzt Apple, Microsoft und wie sie alle heißen da irgendwie Millionen und Abermillionen drauf werfen, um irgendwie den Next-Generation-Codec zu bauen, und Google da erstmal so ein bisschen alleine da steht, muss man mal sehen, ob das nicht nur so eine Google Wave. Also immerhin haben sie ja genug Geld, um da Geld drauf werfen zu können, im Gegensatz zu vielen Open-Source-Varianten und so weiter. Von daher mal schauen.
So, ganz viele Sachen lasse ich jetzt noch raus, die ich hier auf meiner Liste habe. Aber eine Sache wollte ich noch erwähnen und zwar hat...
Einen hab ich noch, einen hab ich noch.
Noch so spannend hab ich MPEG 4.
Genau, das betrifft alle Leute mit SSDs. Ich hab ja bekannt gegeben, dass ich eine SSD in meinem alten Macbook hau. Und ich bin auch immer noch total stoned von diesem... Das ist so schlimm, dass ich den ganzen Tag, nicht den ganzen Tag, aber jeden Tag denke ich darüber nach, was ich tun kann, um meine Festplatten loszuwerden.
Ich seitdem auch.
Also vor allem, gerade um so alte Computer zu pimpen. Ich hab noch, in meiner Wohnung hab ich noch so einen 17 Zoll weißen iMac. Weißt du so erste Chorduo-Geschichte, das erste, was du gerade 64-bit kannst. Und naja, das ist so eine passable Browsing-Station. Aber wenn du den halt auch mal ein bisschen quälst, mit zwei, drei Programmen aufmachen und hier nochmal irgendwie einen Spreadsheet durchackern und so, dann kommt das Ding auch ganz schön ans Husten. Und ich weiß einfach, ich weiß einfach, würde ich da jetzt diese SSD reinstecken, das Teil würde einfach fliegen.
Ja, warum steckst du denn in einen neuen Rechner rein? Du hast ja so ein schickes, neues MacBook Pro umstehen.
Ja, weil ich da halt auf 500 GB bin und 500 GB...
Ja, aber dann ist doch last of all die Spocken mit dem Rahmen...
.doppelfestplatten.
Ja, das ist ja auch noch eine Option, aber das heißt halt auch, Hardware aus meinem Computer auszubauen, die ich vielleicht dann doch auch mal brauch.
Also gerade in den letzten Tagen... Aber wenn das Laufwerk SATA ist, dann kannst du dir so USB-SATA-Schnupschen und Hepfeste halt noch da.
Das ist halt, du weißt ja, so Gebimsel-Peripherie. Wie oft braucht man das? Ich brauch's halt schon auch.
An diesem Rechner oder an einem deiner vielen Rechner?
Ich hab gerade konkret an dem, aber... Also ich hatte zum Beispiel alle CD-Laufwerker hier gerade im Einsatz in den letzten Tagen. Parallel.
RIPRIP-HUHA.
Weil so viele DVDs brennen, musst du in den ganzen Film mit drauf.
Nee, nicht zum Brennen, zum Rippen. Und auch so vor Ort Rippen und so. Also es hat schon seinen Grund, dass da so ein Laufwerk auch noch eingebaut wird von Apple. Es gibt Leute, die brauchen das.
Ja, damit es ein bisschen schwerer wird.
Damit es ein bisschen schwerer wird und damit es ein bisschen größer ist und so weiter. Klar, könnte ich unter Umständen vielleicht tun. Ich könnte aber auch einfach da eine 512 GB SSD reinbauen, aber so viel wirft der Flatter halt jetzt noch nicht ab, dass ich über solche Luxuszüge nachdenken könnte.
SSD ist für alle Mobile-Max-Teile.
Nichts ist insofern Neues passiert. Ich habe allerdings Software bekommen. Und zwar von Patrick aus München, der bekannt ist, vielleicht einigen als Autor von Tools wie Jolly's Fast VNC. Ach der! Und das Screen Recycler, der dann auch über VNC funktioniert, wo du einen zweiten Computer als Zweitbildschirm benutzen kannst und diesen ganzen Kram.
An den habe ich mir übrigens auch gedacht jetzt bei dem Apple TV. Wenn das Streaming tatsächlich von jeder Quelle rausgeht, wäre das natürlich ideal.
Ja, habe ich auch kurz dran gedacht. Ja, herzlichen Dank. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall. Er fummelt gerade an so einem Tool, das trägt den Namen SSD Lifetime und Ziel der ganzen Geschichte ist, dass quasi so eine Voraussage über die Lebenszeit deiner SSD gemacht werden soll. Ob das alles so funktionieren wird?
Ist das auch eine treffende Voraussage?
Das lässt sich derzeit noch nicht so richtig beobachten, weil er ist gerade dabei, diese ganzen Smart-Werte, die diese Platten so rauswerfen, überhaupt erst mal zu parsen und zu reingenieren. Darum geht es eigentlich. Also es ist derzeit eher noch so ein Forschungsprojekt. Und er sucht quasi Beta-Tester oder Alpha-Tester vielleicht, die unter Umständen auf ihrem System mit SSD dieses Tool mal laufen lassen würden, um ihm dann entsprechende Protokolle zuzuschicken, wie sich diese Parameter verändern, in diesen Smart-Protokollnummer rauszukriegen, wie die eigentlich ticken.
Ja, wenn er mir eine SSD gibt, mach ich das gern.
Macht er bestimmt.
Ja, also vor allem Leute, die Apple-SSD-Platten, Samsung-SSDs, Toshiba, Marvell, Kingston-Controller und SLC suchen, verwenden. Da ist er besonders heiß drauf. Und jetzt hab ich ihn gar nicht gefragt, an wen die Leute sich eigentlich wenden sollen.
Geh auf die JollyFast-VNC-Seite und klick auf Kontakt.
Ja, jetzt muss ich mal kurz schauen, ob der überhaupt eine Webseite hat. Genau, das ist jinx.de, jinx.de. Und da gibt es auch ein Impressum und CustomerCare.Jinx.eu. Da schickt er einfach eine Mail hin und sagt, welche SSD-Platte ihr habt und dann, denke ich mal, wird er sich melden und euch gegebenenfalls das Programm zu schicken.
Hat Google jetzt eigentlich schon die neue Inbox endlich? Ach so, du weißt gar nicht, was das ist?
Google die, die mit Spam hast du geschrieben.
Nee, die haben ihren Spam-Filter umgedreht, quasi. Du kriegst jetzt erst den Spam ein. Man kriegt jetzt den Spam und der Rest wird gelöscht, damit man den nicht mehr... Nein, das ist... Bisher wurde ja sozusagen, der Spam-Filter war ja da, um für dich total irrelevante Informationen von vornherein wegzufiltern. Jetzt nutzen sie den auch noch so, dass sie dir für dich extrem relevante Informationen einfach ganz nach vorne packen. Sodass sie dir zuerst die neuen Mails nicht mehr nach Eingangsdatum angezeigt werden, sondern nach wie wichtig ist das für dich. Woran merken sie das? Ob du den Leuten antwortest, ob sie in deinem Adressbuch drinstehen, ob du von dieser Person schon mal Mails gelesen hast und so was alles. Und wahrscheinlich auch an wie viele Leute, die rausgeht, schlicht oder ergreifend.
Und ob das Important Flag gesetzt ist und wie viele Ausrufezeichen.
Je mehr Ausrufezeichen, desto besser. Und wenn Viara dann auftaucht, dann wissen sie, alles klar, das ist super wichtig.
Und wenn du nur irgendwie mit Männern schreibst und keine Frauen in der Liste hast.
Ach guck, ich weiß das auch. Ach du meinst ja, wie ich eine E-Mail-Adresse auf diesem Planeten, auch schon ein M und ein F-Fleck oder ein N oder ein O?
Nö, vor allen Dingen können sie die Namen parsen. Die können auch die Namen parsen. Man, die können Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2 erkennt, das Spracherkennung. Die sind auf jedem Gottverdammten.
Die hören noch Leben, weinen noch raus, ob er überhaupt weiß, was ein Finanzamt ist.
Und vor allen Dingen, Jungs, ist überhaupt klar, die sind auf jedem Gottverdammten, die weist auf dieser Erde.
Und wenn man nicht auf alles, und wenn man nicht noch aufpassen, dann fotografieren sie als Nächstes um so Straßen.
Stell dir erst mal vor, wie das wäre.
Also, mal ehrlich, klar wissen die, ob Annette weiblich oder männlich ist.
Annette? Aha, wär's Annette?
Google weiß, wer Annette ist.
Also, liebe Hörer, wenn ihr wissen wollt, ob Annette weiblich ist, wie man die Telefonnummer auf Finanzamt Körperschaften 2 rauskriegt und sonstige dumme Kommentare über die Welt, dann hört ihr Mobamex live bei euch im Ohr und unlive im Internet runterzuladen, demnächst auch dieser Podcast.
Und jetzt auch zum Flattern.
Genau, wir freuen uns sehr über den Pizza-Beitrag. Das ist definitiv eine tolle Sache.
Auch wenn die Pizza nicht...
Hört nicht auf damit. Ich hab einen sehr klugen Artikel gelesen über Flatter. Ich hab ihn auch gelesen auf Twitter. Ich weiß nicht, hast du wahrscheinlich auch gelesen. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, wie der Titel war. In der schönen Analyse, dass nämlich diese ganze Flatter-Geschichte gar nicht so sehr eine Bezahlung für irgendwas geleistet ist.
Sondern für die Zukunft.
Genau, so eine Investition in die Zukunft. Und ich glaube, so genau funktioniert das auch mit der Innovation.
Flatter wird noch richtig, richtig spannend werden.
Und wir machen nämlich hier auch... Wir bemühen uns ein bisschen um Regelmäßigkeit.
Investiert in unsere Zukunft.
Wir fassen ein Donnerstag ins Auge. Ich weiß nicht, ob es klappen wird, aber wir probieren es zumindest.
Also wenn wir SSDs alle kriegen, ne? Dann podcasten wir jeden Tag.
Nein.
Also mein Kollege auf Arbeit sagt ja auch schon immer, wie du hast ja heute noch gar nicht gesagt, dass du eine SSD willst. Weil ich jetzt so mittlerweile täglich schon so in die Gehirne eingraviere, da auf Arbeit, dass ich ja auch irgendwie extrem viel glücklicher wäre, wenn ich so eine SSD in den Computer hätte.
Ich hab ja auf Windows eine SSD auf Arbeit, aber ist halt unter Windows.
Und Windows schafft auch das für diesen Fall.
Ja, das ist echt sagenhaft, das ist wirklich sagenhaft, dass man alle paar Monate muss diese Platte neu formatiert werden, ansonsten wird die so unerträglich lahm, dass es gar nicht mehr geht.
Du hast eine SSD?
Ja.
Mit Windows. Windows kriegt auch SSD in die Knie.
Vielleicht ist das auf dem Mac genauso. Kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Ich kann durchaus sein, was ich gerade sage, aber glaube ich ihr nicht.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall an eurem SSD-Feedback interessiert.
Genau.
Patrick ist auch sehr an eurem SSD-Feedback. Wir werden SSDs auch nochmal in den Blick machen. Ich mache auch mal ein paar andere Ansagen. Themen für die nächsten Wochen. Ich schaue mir gerade Syncing aller Art an. Da gibt es viel zu testen. Irgendwie Voila und andere Sachen und Crashplan. Es gibt mittlerweile eine ganze Menge Tools, die da auf dem Markt sind und versuchen einen neuen Ansatz in Bezug auf Sharing, Backup etc. zu realisieren. Ich wollte übrigens auch noch über meine Mobile-Meer-Erfahrung reden, aber das können wir jetzt auch nicht mehr hin.
Aber erzähl das doch erstmal deiner Selbsthilfegruppe.
Ihr seid meine Selbsthilfegruppe.
Mein Name ist Zimmut, ich bin Mobile-Meer-Benutzer.
Spatterlau.
Ok, das war die Sonderausgabe hier zum Apple Streaming-Klimbim. Mal gucken, ich hoffe, dass Steve jetzt regelmäßig eine Ansprache hält vor unserer neuen Sendung.
Und ich follow ihm immer noch nicht, weil ich noch nicht iTunes 10 installieren konnte.
Ja, genau. Nächstes Mal reden wir über Ping.
Und?
Tja, das wäre sozusagen das, was du jetzt starten könntest. Das wäre dein Start-up, Max.
Werte von Apple verklagt in drei, zwei, eins.
Nee, Ping ist all about music. Und dann machst du halt so ein Social-Network für... Was gibt es noch so für Daten? Pong ist Ping, Porn ist Porn.
Gut. Na.
Das war's, wir schalten aus, bis bald, tschüss! Tschüss!